bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle édition de senna 360
tout de suite
voici les titres une émission largement
consacré à la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement que vous
pourrez suivre en direct et en
intégralité dans une heure une séance
dominée aujourd'hui par la thématique
des droits des femmes
à la veille du 8 mars journée
internationale des femmes le sénat son
parent de la loi d'orientation des
mobilités en commission les sénateurs
ont largement amendé le texte
gouvernemental pour mettre l'accent sur
le rôle des collectivités et encourager
le développement des transports moins
polluants
c'est une décision qui fera date le
cardinal barbarin et condamné à six mois
de prison avec sursis pour non
dénonciation d'agression sexuelle
l'archevêque de lyon qui annonce
remettre sa démission au pape mais fera
tout de même appel de sa condamnation
et tout au long de cette émission vous
pouvez réagir sur twitter avec le
hashtag sénat 360 pour m'accompagner cet
après midi alexandre poussa et dans
l'hémicycle et tam tran huy en salle des
conférences du sénat
et justement on rejoint tout de suite
alexandre poussard dans l'hémicycle pour
le programme de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement alexandre
louis jérôme une séance de questions
largement consacrée aux droits des
femmes car nous sommes à la veille du 8
mars de la journée internationale des
droits des femmes et la france fait
payet fait partie des pays les mieux
classés au monde en termes de protection
de ces droits des femmes
mais il ya il a des points noirs qu'il
faut noter chaque année 80 mille femmes
sont victimes de viol ou de tentative de
viol selon une étude de l'insee et puis
il ya toujours une inégalité salariale
de 25% entre les hommes et les femmes
alors cette journée des droits des
femmes c'est aussi l'occasion de faire
le premier bilan de la loi du
gouvernement contre les violences
sexuelles et les violences sexistes une
loi portée par la ministre marlène
schiappa dont l'absence est annoncée cet
après midi pour cette séance de
questions d'actualité
et puis les sénateurs reviendrons aussi
sur l'agression de deux surveillants
pénitentiaires à la prison de condé sur
sarthe
et puis il y aura une question sur le
déclin de l'industrie en france merci
beaucoup alexandre pour ce programme et
on va en salle des conférences du sénat
août à mme tran huy vous allez comme
chaque jour récolté les réactions
politiques à l'actualité
et oui et vous l'avez dit jérôme dans
l'actualité il ya l'annoncent par le
cardinal barbarin du fait qu'il remette
sa démission au pape cela alors qu'il a
été condamné à six mois de prison avec
sursis pour non dénonciation d'agression
sexuelle est ce une première victoire
pour la protection de l'enfance
j'interrogerai à ce sujet la présidente
les républicains de la mission
d'information sur la pédophilie
ici au sénat catherine de roche
également au programme il ya à la veille
du 8 mars la journée internationale des
droits des femmes
on s'interrogera aujourd'hui bien sûr le
sexisme sur l'égalité femmes hommes mais
aussi sur la question du sport féminin
c'est ce que je verrai avec la ministre
des sports oksana maracineanu mais on va
également parlé pour commencer de la loi
l'homme cette loi mobilité qui va
commencer son chemin parlementaire au
sénat et qui a notamment pour objectif
de désenclaver les territoires mais avec
quels moyens
avec quels financements ces questions je
déposerai notamment à olivier jacquin
sénateurs socialistes ainsi qu'à youtube
gontard sénateurs écologistes
rattaché au groupe communiste merci
beaucoup tam pour ce programme chargé et
vous venez de l'évoquer 1 c'est le coup
d'envoi au sénat de l'examen de la loi
d'orientation des mobilités un texte
très attendu en la dernière version
d'attentes de 35 ans et le sénat a déjà
fortement amendé le texte du
gouvernement en commission en mettant
notamment l'accent sur le rôle des
collectivités locales les explications
de jordan klein la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire adopté 2 140
amendements parfois à l'unanimité sur ce
texte les sénateurs dénoncent les
nombreuses lacunes présente dans la
version du gouvernement notamment sur le
volet financier on a voté différentes
dispositions financières notamment pour
que les intercommunalités qui se voit
confier la compétence de la mobilité et
les moyens de mettre en oeuvre cette
compétence est également pour que le les
projets en termes d'infrastructures et
d'investissements soient soient
financées et que l'on ne soit pas dans
dans le flou total en matière de
financement en effet les sénateurs
souhaitent que le milliard d'euros
récoltés grâce à la tei cpe c'est taxes
sur les produits énergétiques soient
entièrement consacré au portefeuille de
la mobilité
mais le sénat a aussi ajouté d'autres
points inciter au développement de
nouvelles infrastructures dans les zones
où les offres de mobilité sont rares
favoriser les développements à vélo avec
la création d'un schéma national des
routes pour bicyclettes créer des voies
et des stationnements pour les véhicules
à faibles émissions
la commission a aussi adopté à
l'initiative du sénateur jean sol un
amendement permettant de renforcer la
sécurité des passages à niveaux que vous
avez deux nominations de la signalétique
on se rend compte qu'il ya des feux
aujourd'hui qui sont un maître 25 ou 1 m
il suffirait de les deux les données sur
élevé parce que quand vous vous trouvez
dans un dans un bus ou dans 1 dans un
camion il est très compliqué de deux de
les voir et amir la visibilité on tenait
passagers niveau escompté parfois des yé
d'arbres qui sont très très autres il
suffirait de
les élaguer les sénateurs déplore
l'absence de nombreux sujets notamment
celui du cas des petites lignes
ferroviaires il volonté du gouvernement
le texte sera débattu en séance publique
durant la troisième semaine de mars et
sur ce thème ont rejoint thème tran huy
en salle des conférences du sénat avec
olivier jacquin sénateur socialiste de
la meurthe et moselle oui olivier
jacquin un mot d'abord sur le fait que
ce projet de loi comment son chemin
parlementaire au sénat que son examen a
été reporté d'un mois du fait du grand
débat lorsque vous pensez que ça va
réellement permettre de mieux prendre en
compte les besoins des territoires
ah oui là on est dans une situation
assez confortable au sénat pour
intervenir sur ce texte qui avait une
forte ambition qui vient à point nommé
sur une question qui est posée de passer
du concept de transport à celui de
mobilité j'espère qu'à la fin du texte
elles seront bien des mobilités durables
et pour tous
est-ce que tu néanmoins il ya des
inquiétudes qui demeurent sur ce projet
de loi
d'abord sur la question du financement
on le dit déjà depuis plusieurs jours il
manque 500 millions d'euros à m en a
fait un bon boulot collectif ir à
l'initiative du rapporteur et en même
temps en adoptant des dispositions
financières qui rassure il s'agit de
financer des infrastructures de
transport à long terme on peut pas le
faire en affectant une partie des
dépenses de radars radars qui sont pas
réparés on en a déjà parlé sur public
sénat hélas pour les propositions qui
sont faites hier relève du bon sens et
de la justice fiscale puisqu'il
s'agirait voilà c'est ça la fameuse cas
d'accession des carburants une partie
une petite partie pourrait être affectée
au financement de ces infrastructures de
transport mais je crois qu'on va pas
assez loin dans les domaines de la
justice fiscale et de la justice sociale
je crois aussi que c'est une question
qui est posée en ce moment précis dans
notre pays d'europe de répondre à ces
éléments là vous juger notamment qu'il
n'y a pas assez d'éléments autour de la
question de libéralisation des
transports
alors voilà ça ça relève c'est une
partie de la question de la justice
sociale
mais il en est une autre quand en même
temps n'apporte de réponses financières
mais on rétrograde en commission sur la
question de tarification
solidaires des transports en commun il y
à un amendement fâcher dans ce domaine
là et on va tenter d'agir ou encore plus
complexe mais lorsqu'on dit dans
certaines zones seulement certains types
de véhicules peu polluants peuvent y
aller
comment fait-on pour les français qui
n'ont pas les moyens de travailler ça et
je crois qu'on ne va pas assez loin
là dessus et pour répondre avec votre
question générisation numérisation du
travail c'est les fameux travailleurs
des plateformes numériques ces livreurs
à vélo qui sont dans des conditions
absolument insatisfaisante et fortement
dégradé en étant autant entrepreneurs en
étant en concurrence les uns des autres
et alors que ce secteur des transports
n'est pas délocalisable
pourquoi créton des travailleurs pauvres
d'un nouveau type d esclaves de
l'algorithme dans le pays c'est une
véritable gangrène qui mine la cohésion
notre pays et qui tire tout par le bas
et là qu'est ce qu'on nous propose une
pauvre charte facultative entre les
géants du numérique et ses travailleurs
isolés
le pot de terre contre le pot de fer et
c'est pas grand chose cette charte pour
vous merci le snav également faire
évoluer le texte sur la question des
collectivités ces dernières vont être
chargés d'organiser les déplacements sur
leur territoire alors de quel poisson et
surtout avec quel moyen c'est encore la
question du financement tout à fait ce
texte intéressant de ce point de vue là
il dit il y à un certain nombre de
territoires on n'a pas d'autorités
administratives pour organiser les
mobilités qui sont quelque chose de
coûteux est très complexe et décide de
couvrir la france d'autorité
organisatrice des mobilités bonne chose
manque de bol il n'y avait pas un sou
jusqu'à hier le sénat à l'opposé de
lever la fameuse taxe sur le conte
appelle le versement transport de
pouvoir lever à taux réduit pour les
territoires peu denses de mètres
seulement 0 point 3 % cotisation est là
où il n'y a pas assez de masse salariale
eh bien on complétera par un peu de thé
icpe il ya merci beaucoup olivier
jacquin d'avoir répondu à mes questions
notamment sur toutes ces modifications
qui ont été apportées par le sénat
non messieurs ya beaucoup de creux dans
le texte encore transport de
marchandises
l'aérien
bon voila merci beaucoup sérieux on va
prolonger le débat sur cette loi
d'orientation des mobilités en plateau
avec mes invités didier mandelli bonjour
vous êtes sénateur et l'air de la vendée
et le rapporteur de cette loi au sénat
bien venu sur le plateau face avoue
pierre médevielle sénateur union
centriste de la haute-garonne merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation à vos
côtés camille solo ce bonjour vous êtes
journaliste transport à contexte et
enfin j'accueille olivier razemon
journal transporte également et auteur
du livre chronique impatiente de la
mobilité quotidienne aux éditions rue de
l'échiquier
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors didier mandelli on l'a entendu la
commission a fortement amendé ce texte
il y avait 600 amendements déposés y en
a 2 140 qu'on était adopté il fallait
vraiment revoir beaucoup de choses dans
ce texte où on a modifié
substantiellement pour répondre
d'ailleurs à toutes les interrogations
légitimes de tous nos collègues
effectivement de 140 amendements adoptés
dont 150 à l'initiative du rapporteur
90e pour les collègues beaucoup de
propositions pertinentes ces deux mots
que j'ai employé à plusieurs reprises
hier pour venir conforter et solidifier
ce texte
pierre médevielle c'était la question du
financement essentiellement composé
problème dans ce texte
oui puisque bon c'est une opportunité ça
sert à rien on peut le souligner je
trouve c'est la première fois qu'ils
n'ont pas la première mais c'est une
toute première où le texte arrive au
sénat par lui-même se démarque par le
sénat même c'est le hasard du calendrier
je pense qu'il est aussi peut-être une
marque de confiance de la ministre
didier la 10000 sagesse je crois qu'il
n'a pas eu inflation d'amendements non
obstant trice nous on essaie du groupe
visé pendant le mois les abords des
positions communes faciliter aussi le
travail du rapporteur et se concentrer
sur l'essentiel qui était qui était le
financement pas s'éparpiller sur des
sujets secondaires
camille sée l'os ce texte il a un peu
fourre-tout faut dire qu'il n'avait pas
vu depuis trente cinq ans vraiment
consacré à cette thématique des
transports du coup on retrouve plein de
sujets et c'est un peu compliqué de s'y
retrouver dans cette fameuse seul homme
oui c'est sûr qu'il ya 50 articles vous
avez du vélo vous avez des questions de
gouvernance vous avez des questions de
d'ouverture des données
il ya beaucoup de choses après
effectivement on en fait pas tous les
mêmes pas tous les cas kiena une loi
comme ça vu puisque vous disiez la
précédente date des années 80 donc là
ils ont vraiment voulu remettre tout le
sujet sur la table et tout remettre à
plat niveau alors qu'il ya des
changements très importants ces
dernières c'est parce que c'est un sujet
global des transports oui bien sûr enfin
dans la vie des gens les gens ne sont
pas juste à signer un mode ils les
prennent un peu tous et saad et influent
de l' influence sur plein de pan de leur
vie donc bien sûr que c'est un sujet
global et ya aussi un sujet
d'aménagement du territoire
olivier heureusement justement sur cette
question de l'aménagement des
territoires le sénat a mis l'accent sur
les collectivités c'est peut-être pour
ça finalement que ce texte il démarre au
sénat c'est que beaucoup d'exemples
viennent des collectivités oui il se
passe beaucoup de choses en fait un peu
partout parfois tendance à opposer les
paris et les grandes villes qui vous
l'aurez tous les transports et tout le
monde pourrait se déplacer absolument
sans voiture ce qui est d'ailleurs
beaucoup de gens ne font quand même pas
et puis le reste de la france qui serait
un endroit une sorte de vaste campagne
où il y aurait une des grandes
difficultés pour se déplacer sans
voiture alors qu'en fait c'est beaucoup
plus nuancé et vous le savez d'ailleurs
il ya des villes moyennes y a des et
puis il ya beaucoup de gens qui font des
kits ont des tas d'initiatives dans des
villages de 300 habitants qui dansent
des systèmes de covoiturage dans des des
associations pro vélo qui se montent
dans des villes de 20000 habitants etc
et donc ça c'est plutôt rassurant ça
veut dire que parfois on se moque d'eux
on ricane quand on est voir il va vous
n'allez pas faire du vélo acheté à
libourne et en fait non il faut il
prendre en compte faut vous les
collectivités doivent saisir l'occasion
pour prendre au sérieux tous ces acteurs
de la mobilité
tout le monde ne fait pas 25 km tous les
jours il ya aussi des gens qui font 200
m il ya aussi des gens qui font de 3 4
km qui peuvent tout à fait déplacée et
des bus notamment dans les villes
moyennes qui aujourd'hui sont plutôt
sous utilisé et par contre il ya une
tendance forte et qui n'est pas abordée
par définition dans la loi puisqu'elle
porte sur les transports c'est pendant
ce qu'il continue à vouloir étaler
systématiquement tous les équipements
tous les tous les tous les éléments
structurants d'une ville des hôpitaux
les visas
les zones commerciales les centres
d'assurance maladie etc et donc qui fait
que ben du coup les transports
deviennent plus compliquées a assuré
dans un territoire plus vaste et plus et
aller que dans un territoire plus dense
didier mandelli il faut adapter
notamment le financement en fonction des
zones on l'a dit a pas que les grandes
villes donc notamment vous proposer une
modulation du versement transport des
entreprises pour finalement s'adapter
aux territoires
oui on a fait sauter le verrou en
réalité du transport régulier sur les
territoires peu denses
on peut imaginer que dans la somme de
collectivités qui vont intégrer la
compétence la question du financement
bien sûr elle est cruciale à l'essentiel
et en fait lorsqu'on a voulu c'est
considéré que c'était illusoire de
penser qu'on allait mettre des bus à
haute fréquence par exemple dans tous
les territoires de france enfin c'est
pas ça l'objet est donc c'est permettre
comme vous le disiez à chacun en
fonction de ses besoins et des attentes
de devenir proposer ce qui est plus
pertinent le plus cohérent à l'échelle
du territoire dont convient financer au
travers d'un versement mobilité qui est
minorée un taux minoré et qui vient être
abondée compensé à hauteur d'un niveau
moyen sont entrés dans le détail qui
permettra au travers d'une fraction de
la tei cpe est bien de proposer le
produit sur deux de flécher est de
proposer à l'ensemble des territoires
des moyens suffisants pour proposer des
des moyens de mobilité adapté carmat de
vielles par contre il ya un absent ce
texte et les petites lignes ferroviaires
on en a beaucoup entendu parler au nom
du texte sur la sncf
et là on a un texte sur les mobilités on
parle pas de ces petites lignes menacées
d'une montre optimiste
on les a laissés à la région c'est juste
très sensible sur ma région occitanie la
présidente est d'ailleurs sensible aussi
pour une somme ce que nous sommes en
tournant en matière de mobilité un
tournant dans les centres urbains un
tournant dans les zones rurales
nous on nouvelle mobilité qui nous sont
proposés il faut les financer bien sur
mes gardes gardons à l'esprit
effectivement il se soucie de
péréquation comme didier mandelli entre
les territoires urbains que leurs
problèmes et les territoires ruraux en
simplifiant clarifiant les compétences
et qu'on arrivera à quelque chose de
plus cohérent je crois mais je pour les
lignes les ter se sont très importants
moi si je prends l'exemple d'une
métropole comme toulouse qui a jamais
les grands visionnaires en matière de
transports urbains
nous allons métro qui a été sous
dimensionné une rocade est question tout
le tout le trafic autoroutier deuxième
aéroport qui ne se fera pas le tgv qui
n'est pas là dont les accès sont de plus
en plus compliquées et les lignes
secondaires sont très importantes pour
l'accès des ruraux à à la métropole
donc nous sommes et resterons très
vigilants sur ce sujet on l'a entendu un
des exemples existent dans les
territoires dans l'agglomération de
mulhouse notamment qui a mis en place un
compte mobilité unique qui permet
d'accéder à tous les modes de transport
du territoire une première en europe
reportage sur place de mickaël spitzberg
michael granger vite à mulhouse depuis
toujours et depuis six mois
il utilise la nouvelle application mise
en place par la communauté
d'agglomération lecomte mobilité une
interface qui gère les différents modes
de transport ainsi que les parkings
disponibles dans les 39 communes et pour
les trois cent mille habitants que
compte l'agglomération et ce qui séduit
avant tout la simplicité le tram c'est
c'est une stabilité parce que j'ai
besoin de chercher de la monnaire ou
d'acheter les tickets ou de prévente et
higuain et puis après pour les autres
modes de transport sans permettre en une
semaine voitures en location que qu'un
vélo disponible partout dans la vie
pratique l'application offre aussi
d'autres intérêts une facture unique qui
regroupe tous les frais de transport
payable en fin de mois
une adhésion facilité à tous les
services et des tarifs préférentiels
avantage de l'application sont à éviter
d'avancer les cautions pour le vélo est
pour et pour la voiture
donc ça c'était c'était aussi un choix
de passer par là parce que ça m'évitait
de leur débauche de redéposer en fait ce
dépôt de garantie et après au niveau des
tarifs pour le vélo il ya un avantage
sur l'abonnement l'abonnement est un peu
moins cher pour la voiture on a plus on
a plus d'abonnements et pour le bus et
le tram en fait on est partis sur des
tarifs assez avantageux par rapport aux
tarifs au ticket à l'unité
résultat pour mickaël 20% d'économies
sur ses dépenses de transport
c'est ici qu'a été élaborée
l'application une prouesse technique un
mélange d'opérateurs publics et privés
sur un même support sans abonnement le
comte mobilité c'est une première en
europe avec l'ambition de s'étoffer
encore jamel améliorée dans un point de
vue aussi fonctionner même si chaud sous
2 h de nouveaux services par exemple
la location longue durée le vélo et
notamment les vélos à assistance
électrique de l'agglomération
on imagine également intégrer le
stationnement en voirie donc les
horodateurs mais aussi plus tard le ter
le covoiturage les taxis ou encore les
bornes de rechargement électrique
mais avant d'être une application
lecomte mobilité c'est une volonté
politique porté par cet homme depuis
plus de cinq ans l'objectif final qu'on
essaie d'atteindre c'est de dire quel
que soit l'endroit où vous résidez quel
que soit le lieu où vous voulez aller
pour le boulot pour l'hôpital pour tout
séjour vous ayez un moyen de transport
alternatif
il n'y a pas que la voiture en usage en
solo qui existe il ya du vélo il ya
d'autopartage voilà aimé essayer et
pourrait mais il faut vous essayez le
développement du service a coûté 700
mille euros 25 % de cette somme a été
prise en charge par l'état
la suite pour devenir en beauce et la
mise en place du transport à la demande
pour les zones les moins denses de
l'agglomération un service qui sera
évidemment disponible sur le compte
mobilité on l'a vu cet exemple de
mulhouse il ya plusieurs choses en tirer
il ya d'abord la transition numérique 1
qui permet si les nouveaux usages
camille seul os ça c'est un aspect
important du texte les transformations
numérique est ce que ça change pour les
transports oui à toute une partie du
texte effectivement sur ce qui concerne
ce sujet et ça implique d'abord d'ouvrir
les données parce qu'en fait pour
l'instant chacun garde ses propres
données donc il ya pas d'interactions
possibles et donc c'est très difficile
donc là ils ont fait ce travail avec les
opérateurs à mulhouse mais ce qui ce qui
était pas complètement dit c'est que ça
a pris des mois de négocier et de
convaincre chacun qu'il ne risquait pas
de perdre la main sur ces données que ce
soit automatique finalement mais c'est
ce que va prévoir le texte est
normalement c'est quoi c'est la ratp
sera obligé de donner toutes ces données
elles ratp le fait déjà en grande partie
tous les opérateurs tous les acteurs de
mobilité y compris les hameaux m mais ce
seront les mêmes qui vont piloter en
réalité ces données et pour pour
l'utilisateur ce sera une une prestation
il faudra payer un minimum pour pouvoir
avoir accès à ces données
ce qu'on a voulu faire également s'est
évité l'intermédiation qu'on a connu
dans certains secteurs d'activité je
pense à l'hôtellerie notamment en
laissant le pouvoir aux collectivités
locales et aux oiseaux à même d'assurer
la maîtrise de
de ses volumes de données mais ce qu'est
ce qui est fait à mulhouse est assez
exemplaire et demain sur tout le
territoire national ce sera de la même
façon pour un voyage d'un bout à l'autre
du pays avec une seule un seul billet
olivier razemon chronique est impatiente
de la mobilité quotidienne s'impatiente
mais ça commence à bouger dans les
territoires et là notamment sur le
multimodal
à terme ce système il permettra même de
commander un taxi bus et parfois déjà
possible dans certaines villes
d'ailleurs d'europe 1 s'est passé
vraiment le premier mondial mais oui un
pastis et l'impatience est très
important dans les transports on est
tous impatients
c'est un sujet sur lesquels on a tous un
avis parce que on est concerné et on
quand ça marche pas ça devient très
facile de râler c'est la sncf c'est les
bouchons les élus là vous en prenez à
chaque fois plein votre grade
à chaque fois que quelqu'un fonction
transports ne fonctionnent pas et en
fait c'est un sujet très sérieux très
important parce que individuellement
peut pas régler tous les problèmes
un opérateur ne suffit pas à régler tous
les problèmes on l'a vu et donc c'est un
sujet extrêmement sérieux finalement je
suis heureux de voir que de plus en plus
d'élus d'ailleurs s'intéressent à ce
sujet je crains toujours un petit peu
mais je crois que m'avait un peu rassuré
pour le ces dames on va voir à
l'assemblée quand même ces initiatives
individuelles de parlementaires qui se
disent ah oui mais l'autre jour j'ai
croisé quelqu'un qui m'a dit qu'il
pouvait pas faire tel trajet donc c'est
impossible pour tout le monde il inverse
et il faut un petit peu se méfier de
cette généralisation de sa situation
personnelle parce que c'est un sujet
tellement finalement tellement vécu
individuellement que c'est facile
ensuite de le voilà de vouloir
généraliser pierre médevielle ce texte
il a été reporté parce qu'il y avait les
gilets jaunes qui s'étaient mobilisés
contre une taxe carbone donc on est au
coeur de cette problématique des
mobilités tout à fait aux mouvements qui
perdure bon salaire de se calmer mais
c'est un sujet vaste taxe carbone
transition énergétique on a vu la
numérisation aussi bons qu'ils amènent
d'aider des solutions je ferai des
solutions mais juste bon évidemment
qu'ils effectuent fiscalement ce soit
acceptable c'était le problème de la
taxe sur les produits carbonés qui ne
devait ce qui n'allait pas être affecté
la transition énergétique et ça l'a
rendu d'autant plus insupportable
qu'elle touchait les populations rurales
et des gens qui sont obligés de prendre
leur véhicule tous les jours là là c'est
vrai que la numérisation
à ramène cette simplification qui va
permettre je crois d'améliorer et de
simplifier le juge chargé des transports
et ça c'est important ce que vous disiez
cremis l'os sur sur cet aspect
finalement de simplification
fluidification est ce que tous les
réseaux sont pas forcément reliés pensée
globale ils sont pensés chacun de leur
côté et là faut réussir à remettre du
lien ont tout ça mais c'est justement
l'objectif de la loi est ce que disait
didier mandelli tout à l'heure sur le
volet gouvernance
en réalité la donc vous aurez toujours
quelqu'un une administration enfin une
autorité organisatrice comme on dit dans
le jargon qui s'en occupera et en plus
toutes les collectivités vont devoir un
peu coopérer entre elles pour que ce
soit mieux articuler c'est ce qu'on
appelle les contrats opérationnels de
mobilité qui avait été prévu par le
ministère des transports qui avait
disparu leur demande du moment des
arbitrages et qui aurait été réintégré
par les sénateurs certainement avec une
grande bienveillance de la ministre est
donc tout ça je considère et donc tout
ça doit permettre justement mieux
articuler que les réseaux se parlaient
entre eux et comment parler des données
tout à l'heure et de ce genre de système
avec des abonnements comme on dit sans
couture pareil ça permettra de
finalement vous pourrez faire un trajet
en utilisant plusieurs modes et c'est
probablement ça qui va permettre aux
gens de se dire bon je laisse de côté ma
voiture pour ses trajets là didier
mandelli c'est la fin de la concurrence
ceci entre les agglomérations il ya une
période tout le monde voulait son
aéroport il y avait six villes dans une
région qu en avait un qui est ce qui
pousse et c'est c'est aussi penser façon
un peu plus collectif pour les élus qui
ont aussi leur part à prendre oui il ya
une forme à la fois de rationalisation
parce que les élus je l'espère en tout
cas son responsable
et puis nos concitoyens aussi l'objectif
au travers de ce projet de loi est celui
que nous avons assignés nous en
modifiant d'ailleurs en reportant
l'article 30 avant l'article 1er pour
bien montrer qu'on était dans une
logique d'aménagement du territoire et
c'est l'objectif c'est prévoir les
aménagements et les investissements sur
une échelle qui est de non pas deux ans
ou de cinq ans mais plutôt à 10 et 30
ans à moyen et long terme ce qui manque
réellement notre pays depuis longtemps
et donc et en fonction de ces critères
voilà on priorise ont fait pas de
promesses inconsidérées et on vient
effectivement mettre en oeuvre les
projets pour lesquels on a un
financement d'assurer merci à tous les
quatre d'avoir participé à ce débat
qu'on va prolonger un petit peu tout de
suite en retrouvant thème traduit en
salle des conférences du sénat qui est
avec guillaume gontard sénateur
écologiste de l'isère oui guillaume
gontard et on sort d'un débat sur la loi
l'homme
cette loi a notamment pour objectif d'en
finir avec le tout voiture est ce que
pour vous c'est une ambition qui vous
satisfait vous qui êtes écologistes et
bien sûr les les orientations qui a dans
la loi l'homme sont sont intéressantes
sont pour certaines pour certaines
satisfaisante par contient un vrai
problème qui est à la fois le
financement
et puis la question des transports en
commun des transports publics je dirais
du transport de masse et notamment de
toutes ses lignes qui sont des vrais
colonne vertébrale sur l'ensemble de nos
territoires et qui disparaissent petit à
petit et sur laquelle on n'a aucune
réponse
voilà et sur laquelle on n'a aucune
réponse on n'avait aucune réponse dans
la loi ferroviaire ou plutôt des
mauvaises réponses
on nous a promis des choses sur la
source sur la sur cette loi mobilité
et bien force est de constater que pour
l'instant nous n'avons rien que ça soit
en termes de financement ou même
d'objectifs pour pour maintenir ces
lignes qui sont vraiment la colonne
vertébrale de notre territoire
alors bien sûr que c'est intéressant de
pouvoir réfléchir sur le dernier
kilomètre sur d'autres types de mobilité
notamment en zone rurale mais il me
semble que cette question là est
primordial il la bête band fait valoir
que l'agenda que la france s'est fixée
avec l'accord de paris et le plan climat
sont à l'honneur avec ce projet de loi
ce que vous jugez que cette exacte bas
est ce que c'est exactement ce que ce
que ce que je disais c'est à dire que on
est on est forcément en décalage
puisqu'il ya des bonnes intentions il ya
des
intéressante mais toujours en même temps
on n'est pas capable de soutenir nos
infrastructures et gérer des transports
du quotidien qui existe actuellement
alors lors de l'audition d'elisabeth
bernina quelques jours vous l'aviez
beaucoup interpellé sur les autoroutes
alors comment ce projet de la concerne
at il tout d'abord les autoroutes
oui donc je suis et je suis rapporteur
de ce projet de loi du groupe crc eux
déposé par eliane assassi sur la
renationalisation des concessions
d'autoroutes qui va être débat qui va
être battu qui va être débattu cet après
midi moi ce que je trouve intéressant
sûr c'est que le débat en fait c'est
déplacé c'est à dire que quasi tout le
monde maintenant et on l'a vu en
commission est d'accord sur le constat
de dire que cette privatisation de 2006
a été une grave erreur que ça a été
quelque chose qu'il ne fallait pas faire
qui ne fallait pas renouveler on a vu
dans le débat dans le débat sur les
sociétés concessionnaires ont fait des
profits exagérés gérer et sur le fait
qu' on pourrait se dire que ces profits
pourrait justement servir à financer nos
infrastructures et je parlais je parlais
notamment des lignes ferroviaires
donc ça me pousse à me paraît
indispensable donc le débat s'est
déplacé maintenant qu'est ce qu'on nous
dit on nous dit non mais il faut
attendre la fin des concessions entre
2031 et 2086 pour pour certaines moi ça
me paraît dangereux parce que à la fois
on s'aperçoit que on repousse sans cesse
c'est à dire que à chaque fois le
gouvernement à 7
cette tendance est facilitée souvent sur
la pression aussi des concessionnaires
autoroutiers de prolonger les
concessions forcément d'augmenter les
tarifs pour pouvoir faire d'autres
d'autres travaux mais donc du coup de
repousser sans cesse et je pense qu'à un
moment il faut c'est un vrai choix
politique il faut savoir se dire stop et
que la l'état puisse reprendre la main
sur quelque chose qui est quand même
stratégique pour notre pays mais une
nationalisation immédiate aurait aussi
un coût est réaliste aujourd'hui avec
l'état budgétaire du pays oui bah y'a il
ya une réponse très simple le cap 28 et
50 le coût est de l'ordre de 50
milliards c'est ce qui a été à peu près
vu avec avec la
fr le secoue ce coût de 50 milliards moi
ce que je voulais juste te dire c'est
qu'en 2006 quand les sociétés ont repris
ont racheté les concessions on était de
l'ordre de 40 milliards avec avec la
dette qui a été qui a été reprise qu'est
ce qu'elles ont fait elles ont emprunté
on a vu qu'elles sont très vite
remboursé et que ça a été plutôt quelque
chose de juin donc il me semble que
l'état peut tout à fait faire la même
chose et donc emprunter et se rembourser
puisque privatisation ne veut pas
forcément dire gratuité merci beaucoup
guillaume contraire d'avoir répondu à
une nation si beaucoup ta mais ont
rejoint alexandre poussard dans
l'hémicycle pour évoquer une preuve
aussi une proposition de loi communiste
un débattu aujourd'hui sur la
nationalisation justement des sociétés
d'autoroutes alex ans et oui jérôme les
sénateurs communistes proposent que
l'état tout simplement rachète les
concessions accordées aux 20 sociétés
privées qui exploite aujourd'hui neuf
mille deux cents kilomètres d'autoroutes
en france ces sociétés ont la main sur
les autoroutes depuis 2005 et les
sénateurs communistes dénoncent les
profits financiers exagéré réalisés par
ces sociétés sur le dos des
automobilistes
alors il faut savoir que ces entreprises
réalisent 8 milliards de chiffre
d'affaires par an ce chiffre d'affaires
a augmenté de 42 % entre 2009 et 2016 et
les sénateurs communistes regrette que
la hausse de 20% en dix ans des tarifs
de péage se fasse au détriment des
automobilistes alors il faut préciser
c'est cette hausse de tarif de péage est
due pour moitié à l'inflation
alors évidemment cette renationalisation
des autoroutes a un coût qui est estimé
entre 28 et 50 milliards d'euros et ce
coup fait tiquer la majorité sénatoriale
qui estime que l'état n'a pas les moyens
et n'est pas prêt aujourd'hui pour
reprendre l'exploitation des autoroutes
en france ce texte a donc peu de chances
d'être adopté cet après midi au sénat
merci alexandre à la veille de la
journée internationale des femmes la
séance de questions d'actualité abordera
très largement la question de leurs
droits et de l'égalité femmes hommes et
alors que la parole se libère dans de
nombreux domaines comme les médias en
politique cela bouge également jonathan
du prix y est allé demander aux
sénatrice leurs impressions sur le sujet
on regarde je veux bien croire que votre
langue a fourché
dit madame la ministre la scène se passe
en novembre 2018 au sénat face à l'élu
de la meuse gérard longuet la secrétaire
d'état à la transition écologique brune
poirson s'exaspère non je ne veux pas
que vous m'appeliez chers amis je
m'appelais madame la ministre
pour répondre à votre question cette
séquence illustre un problème persistant
les femmes aux responsabilités sont
souvent la cible d'attaqués visant à
décrédibiliser leurs actions et leur
légitimité même en politique c'est
tellement ancré dans les comportements
les femmes ont elles mêmes tellement
l'habitude et sont tellement adapté à
vivre avec à survivre et à faire comme
ce qu'elles ont à faire malgré sexisme
on a fini par ne plus voir ne pas le
voir et donc il faut le montrer il faut
en parler il faut le désigner pour le
faire pour l'éradiquer si de récentes
affaires comme la sphère beaupain ont
permis à des femmes politiques de
libérer leur parole
il faut aller plus loin selon annick
billon la présidente de la délégation
aux droits des femmes du sénat
la difficulté c'est la suite qui est
donné aujourd'hui les statistiques le
prouvent
de plus en plus de femmes dénoncent les
violences dénonce le sexisme mais il y a
très peu de condamnations
derrière donc un sentiment d'impuissance
par rapport à ces condamnations
christine lagarde est la plus jeune
sénatrice de la haute assemblée à 34 ans
l'élu avoue n'avoir jamais ressenti le
poids du sexisme en politique
pour elle les mentalités sont en train
de changer et j'ai vraiment l'impression
que l'ensemble de mes collègues et lâche
thierry collègues masculins ont bien
sentiment que on ne peut plus permettre
tout ce qu'on pouvait se permettre il ya
peut-être une dizaine d'années au
sexisme s'ajoute un problème de
représentation des femmes en politique
malgré les lois sur la parité en france
83% des mairies sont tenus par des
hommes seulement six femmes ont été
élues à la tête de villes de plus de
100000 habitants et pour m'accompagner
jusqu'à la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement j'accueille
sur le plateau mais invité élisabeth
doineau bonjour vous êtes sénatrice
union centriste de la mayenne face avoue
françoise cartron bonjour bonjour
sénatrice la république en marche de la
gironde et enfin jacques gérault ma
chère bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénateur les
républicains de l'oise alors on a vu
dans ce sujet élisabeth doineau les
mentalités évoluent en politique aussi
mais peut-être pas assez vite sur cette
question du sexisme
ça n'a sans doute pas évolué assez vite
alors moi je représente un groupe qui a
justement le plus la plus forte
proportion de femmes présentes et donc
j'en suis assez fier à l'union centriste
et est donc plutôt bien représentés si
on peut dire aujourd'hui je n'ai pas
ressenti sur mon parcours politique
beaucoup de difficultés concernant ma
présence dans des instances ou en tout
cas pour défendre ma présence pour les
élections donc
j'observe que selon les territoires il
peut y avoir effectivement plus de
combats à mener que d'autres mais dans
un territoire rural comme le mien le
département de la mayenne
en tout cas j'ai senti un certain
respect vis-à-vis des femmes et je crois
qu'on le doit à toutes celles qui nous
ont précédés à toutes celles qui ont
défendu l'idée que les femmes devaient
avoir des postes importants en politique
comme ailleurs est aujourd'hui au sénat
on n'a sans doute pas suffisamment de
femmes disent qu'elles représentent
qu'un tiers de l'hémicycle mais je pense
que nous aurons des jeunes femmes comme
tout à l'heure nous avons vu notre jeune
collègue qui viendront éclairer et qui
viendront effectivement faire bouger les
choses
françoise cartron la république en
marche est présentée énormément de
femmes à l'assemblée nationale mais les
postes importants président de
l'assemblée nationale premier ministre
tous à elles en sont encore exclus c'est
c'la maintenant le combat c'est vraiment
les postes importants pour les femmes
oui alors déjà il faut saluer l'arrivée
massive des femmes à l'assemblée
nationale ce qui a changé
le paysage quand même et qui a donné
lieu quand même à beaucoup je trouve de
propos parfois désobligeants parce que
on nous a bien parlé qu'il fallait du
renouvellement on a eu des femmes
on a eu des femmes jeunes et bien sûr on
a tout de suite dit abel sont
expérimentés inexpérimenté ab voyez ça
peut faire où elles sont pas assez
présentes sur le terrain elles ont pas
les codes
donc c'est quand même pas facile bien
payé une arrivée en force
c'est quand même pas la légitimité ne va
pas automatiquement avec non je crois
qu'il ya du chemin du chemin à faire et
c'est ce que vous soulignez la
légitimité de va pas avec donc quand il
s'agit des postes importants décisionnel
on trouve toujours l'argument pour qui
un homme plus compétent pour prétendre à
ce poste
donc il y a encore beaucoup de chemin à
parcourir
jérôme bascher votre party les
républicains il a souvent payer des
pénalités pour pas présentés à cette
femme est ce que vous sentez que ça
bouge enfin aussi dans le parti
politique d'une part la parité sur
toutes les listes fait du bien et je dis
très simplement dans le département de
l'oise dont je suis élu au conseil
départemental peux vous dire que les
mentalités les débats ont totalement
changé dorénavant alors que c'est
paritaire et nous avons la chance
d'avoir une présidente de conseil
départemental
il y en a peu il y en a peu elle est
présidente et j'ai voté pour elle plus
cher plus sérieusement au delà de ce
fait avec de qui c'est sérieux mais
saisir c'est anecdotique on est aussi
sur l'ensemble de la france et
l'ensemble du sujet sur l'ensemble du
sujet la dir les maires 87 % des hommes
oui mais il ne faut pas croire que tout
va se faire d'un coup on veut faire tout
d'un claquement de doigts le sens est le
bon il ne faut pas désigner alors que
vous aviez longtemps des conseils
municipaux uniquement masculin et
notamment à la campagne parce que ce
qu'on oublie de dire c'est que des
souvent à la campagne on a déjà du mal à
boucler des listes municipales
on a beaucoup de mal et aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de mains
deux petites copines me disent mais en
plus je ne vais pas trouver de femmes
parce qu'elles n'ont pas le temps ou
alors on va les avoir sur une liste
elles ne viendront pas au conseil mais
sa musique municipale
ce sont des réalités de terrain ce sont
des réalités de terrain moi j'ai
beaucoup de conseils municipaux qui
n'arrive plus être au complet et c'est
dommage
les femmes comme les hommes sauf que
souvent les femmes c'est d'être un tort
aujourd'hui mais s'occupe aussi encore
des enfants et du ménage
en plus du ménage pas de faire le ménage
évidemment mais de le faire vivre le
foyer de faire vivre le foyer je préfère
être précis pour éviter toute
interprétation seront peu rigoler tous
ces sujets là on peut avoir la
caricature facile mais c'est quand on
est sérieux et reprenant des arguments
extrêmement sérieux en étant précis
qu'on fait progresser la cause
je crois que c'est ça l'intérêt non moi
je voudrais je suis désolé je vais
témoigner en faux parce que alors
lorsque j'ai été élu maire de la ville
de 6000 habitants en 1995 par la
préhistoire j'étais la seule femme maire
de toute l'agglomération bordelaise
les seules femmes mères que l'on
trouvait ailleurs
c'était dans le rural dans les toutes
petites communes
là où il n'y avait pas de grands enjeux
de pouvoir et où finalement ébats des
femmes se sont dévoués d'exception une
statistique ce qui l inverse l heure à
mai - je dis je parle du réel je pars
durel j'étais la seule femme de
l'agglomération bordelaise nous étions
95,3 femme mère pour toute la région
aquitaine d'une ville de plus de 5000
habitants
c'était quand même un constat terrible
c'était alors le chemin à progresser la
loi a fait beaucoup nous bien qu'elle
ait été controversée moi j'ai toujours
été pour la loi sur la parité
parce que c'était le seul moyen de
débloquer les situations mais maintenant
comme vous l'avez dit il faut passer à
l'étape suivante
élisabeth doineau comment faire bouger
dans les collectivités dans les mairies
alors moi je crois que nos institutions
ne sont pas préparés justement à
accueillir plus de femmes
quand on voit par exemple des jeunes
femmes qui s'investissent les parents
jeudi rond peuvent avoir partagé
les tâches ménagères et les tâches
familiales mais néanmois quelquefois il
ya plus personne pour garder les enfants
est-ce qu'on va préparer des crèches
pour accueillir les enfants le soir
pendant les réunions du contenu les
assauts du chant pas assez prête on va
aller voir justement une ministre au
micro d' homme traduit en salle des
conférences et la ministre des sports
roxana maracineanu oui avec roxana
maracineanu d'abord une question puisque
l'on parle de sexisme en politique vous
ai bien quel est votre ressenti déjà
deux femmes politiques sur ce sujet ce
que c'est un sujet sur lequel on avancer
sur lequel il ya plus d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes aujourd'hui en
politique hoyau nettement depuis mon
arrivée au gouvernement en septembre
dernier je n'ai à aucun moment pu
ressentir de discrimination de ce côté
là c'est vrai qu'il ya des femmes
politiques qui s'étaient sentis
discriminés au sein de l'hémicycle etc
rappelle cécile duflot par exemple il ya
encore quelques années vous pensez que
c'est avancer parce qu'aussi elles ont
porté ce combat sur la place publique
parce qu'on en a parlé que nous aussi on
peut bénéficier aujourd'hui de
conditions qui sont à mon avis à mon
goût paritaire entre les femmes et les
hommes
en tout cas dans les institutions et au
sein de ce gouvernement alors à la
veille du 8 mars nous allons aussi
parler ensemble sport féminin c'est un
sport qui reste insuffisamment valorisé
par les médias aujourd'hui roxana
maracineanu oui c'est vrai que pour
progresser dans ce domaine pour avoir
plus de femmes pratiquante notamment est
aussi une image plus féminine du sport
on a besoin de plus de modèles que ce
soit dans les vitrines et médiatique
c'est à dire à la télévision plus de
sport féminin médiatisé mais aussi en
qualité le change un peu aujourd'hui
ou pas encore au passé oui alors jusqu'à
maintenant c'est vrai que les
journalistes mettait en avant le fait
qu'on n'avait pas assez de résultats au
niveau au niveau des filles c'est pour
ça qu'on pouvait pas passer des
événements sportifs d'ampleur
internationale à la télé aujourd'hui il
y à des femmes performantes et nous on
fait ce qu'il faut aussi pour qu' il ya
plus de sportifs de haut niveau et
qu'aujourd'hui plus de femmes s'engagent
dans ces carrières sportives
c'est pas évident parce qu'à le problème
de la maternité il ya aussi le problème
du double projet études et sport et on
sait que les femmes et les filles les
jeunes filles sont plus sensibles et
sont moins enclines à à se dédier à une
carrière sportive et laisser tomber
leurs études à côté et c'est aussi voilà
en sac on qu'on agit aujourd'hui au
ministère pour pouvoir proposer ce
double sportifs et les accompagner au
mieux pour qu'elle puisse être la
vitrine pour plus de femmes dans le
sport
né à quelques mois de la coupe du monde
de football féminine à ce que vous
comptiez sur cet événement pour susciter
un engouement est peut-être plus de
vocations aussi lieu dans le football
féminin
oui au niveau des pratiquants de haut
niveau mais surtout sur l'accès à la
pratique et l'accès à tous les sports
plus de mixité plus de petit garçon qui
puisse faire de la danse qui puisse
faire de l'équitation plus de petites
filles qui puisse faire du football ou
du rugby - de ce terreau et alors là
c'est ça notre notre ambition favoriser
l'accès à la pratique pour tous au
niveau du grand public c'est ça aussi le
l'enjeu de cette coupe du monde féminine
parce qu'on va amener des familles au
stade on va amener des mères avec leurs
enfants et on va pouvoir aussi parlé de
plus deux dirigeantes dans le sport plus
d'entraîneur dans le sport plus aussi
des arbitres sur les matches qu'on
regarde à la télé et ça c'est important
pour arriver à une vraie parité
un mot sur le sexisme dans le sport
aujourd'hui alors il ya toujours déjà le
fait que les salaires féminins soient
pas à égalité avec les salaires
masculins puis on se rappelle il ya
encore eu très récemment des propos très
désobligeant par exemple de il y avait
eu denis balbir qui avait parlé du fait
qu'une femme ne pouvait pas commenter le
football on voit qu'il ya quand même
encore bien du chemin à faire
oui surtout dans le paysage
journalistique du sport aujourd'hui il
ya beaucoup de commentateurs sommes
beaucoup de journalistes hommes qui
parlent du sport et je crois qu'à voir
plus de femmes
pratique quand dirigeante haut niveau et
puis surtout journalistes aussi ça va
apporter une autre vision du sport une
vision plus en adéquation avec le sport
santé le sport éducation le sport au
plus près des attentes des pratiquants
pas seulement le sport compétition
c'est sûr qu'on va en parler
différemment et qu'une femme parle
différemment qu'un homme mais tout le
monde n'a pas envie d'entendre que la
voix des hommes s'exprimer sur ce sujet
là qui concerne toute la société
il vient merci à beaucoup d'avoir
répondu à mes questions merci dame
elisabeth doineau c'est dans toute la
société un policier export les études
tout ça il faut bouger sur dans tous les
domaines il faut bouger dans tous les
domaines et pour que les femmes accèdent
à tous les postes de responsabilité faut
aussi leur donner les moyens
et moi je dis que les institutions comme
les grandes entreprises ou même toutes
les formes de
deux représentations possibles doivent
permettre une offre pour la garde des
enfants pour par exemple laisser son
linge dans une buanderie pour en tout
cas faciliter la vie du quotidien et
leur permettre de dégager du temps pour
être présente là où elles doivent être
présentes au même titre que les hommes
on va évoquer en maintenant un tout
autre sujet puisqu'on a parlé de la
décision justice surprise à lyon où le
cardinal barbarin vient d'être condamné
à six mois de prison avec sursis pour
non dénonciation d'agression sexuelle
l'archevêque de lyon va remettre sa
démission au pape françois le résumé des
faits paralysé boissons
une déclaration qui n'a duré qu'une
minute il n'en fallait pas plus au
primat des gaules pour annoncer remettre
sa démission au pape
une décision qui intervient après sa
condamnation survenu ce matin
indépendamment de mon sort personnel je
tiens à redire d'abord ma compassion
pour les victimes et toute la place
qu'elle est leur famille garde dans ma
prière
j'ai décidé d'aller voir le saint père
pour lui remettre ma démission
il me recevra dans quelques jours
l'archevêque de lyon est accusé d'avoir
fermé les yeux sur les agressions
pédocriminels du père prenne à survenus
dans les années 80 et 90
les cinq autres membres de l'église
poursuivi à ses côtés ont eux été
relaxés
une condamnation surprise en effet à
l'issue du procès en janvier
la procureure n'avait pas requis de
condamnation estimant que la non
dénonciation des faits était prescrite
si le cardinal était absent à l'énoncé
du jugement ses avocats ont annoncé
vouloir faire appel une déception
mesurée puisque nous sommes en première
instance et je rappelle tout de même que
c'est
à la fin des débats et à la fin du
processus juridique que la vérité
judiciaire sera dite six mois de prison
avec sursis pour le cardinal barbarin
une décision symbolique est exemplaire
pour les victimes se dire aujourd'hui
que on a eu gain de cause
c'est se dire aussi que ce combat
n'était pas vain et et finalement on a
vraiment fait bouger les lignes
et puis et puis se dire aussi personne
n'est au dessus des lois des faits loin
d'être unique en 2001 et 2018 des
évêques avaient été condamnés dans des
dossiers similaires et sur ce sujet ont
rejoint thème traduit en salle des
conférences avec catherine de roche la
présidente de la mission d'information
sur la pédophilie
ici au sénat catherine de roche votre
réaction au fait que le cardinal
barbarin annonce remettre sa démission
au pape et en même temps il fait appel
je rappelle qu'il a été condamné en
première instance à six mois de prison
avec sursis pour non dénonciation
d'agression sexuelle alors c'est vrai
que bon je vais commenter la décision de
justice art vous savez que ce n'est pas
la règle bon la justice a pensé qu' au
regard des faits qui lui étaient
reprochés cela méritait une condamnation
il fait appel ce qui oscille à la
liberté de ti soin de tout citoyen qui a
été condamné il remet sa démission au
pape ce qui peut s'entendre je veux dire
on est sur un sujet qu est tellement
grave que celui des abus sexuels dans
l'église de cette forme de dénier de
martha de volonté de de traiter ces
affaires au sein d'églises sans quille
et de retentissement public et est donc
en faisant abstraction parce qu'elle a
des valeurs civiques et vous qu'ils
remettent ça dessine je pense alors ça
c'est difficile de juger mais je pense
qu'en se faire cesser responsable mais
c'est difficile d'exercer lorsqu'on est
condamné pour un tel acte je pense que
l'église a pris la mesure le pape
françois mais comme l'a fait benoît 16 a
été un rôle a été très clair sur ce que
doit être la réaction l'église face à ce
cas parce qu'on était des abus les
années passées sur des mineurs je pense
qu'en effet cette omerta ce déni cette
volonté de régler les problèmes au sein
de l'église n'est plus possible
donc je pense qu'il faut en effet
prendre les décisions qui s'imposent au
regard de ce que sont les les actes et
aussi les douleur et la souffrance des
victimes parce que c'est une première
victoire pour la protection de l'enfance
et notamment pour la parole libérée un
une association vous aviez d'ailleurs
attendu je pense que pour les
associations de victimes c'est la
reconnaissance de leur statut de
victimes par rapport à ce qu'est en
effet l'institution
c'est très vrai pour l'église c'est vrai
dans d'autres institutions le voit dans
le sport on voit en effet des actes
commis sur des mineurs l'importante
éducation senti seul contre tous mes
amis dont 10 étaient les associations
qui sont seuls contre tous je pense que
ce qui est important c'est que à la fois
dans les institutions que l'église
prenne la mesure du problème des actes
c'est de la pédocriminalité ce sont des
crimes
donc ils doivent être soumis aux règles
de la justice comme tout crime et je
pense que cette volonté qui a été
longtemps celle de l'église de mettre un
peu un couvercle sur le dossier ce n'est
plus acceptable
ce n'est pas plus acceptable que dans
l'église quand plus un côté très sacré
que salo ou en effet elle est censée
représenter le bien à la une une valeur
symbolique très très forte pour les
fidèles et pour la communauté religieuse
je pense qu'il y allait de l'avenir de
l'église de prendre ce problème en face
mais c'est vrai pour d'autres
institutions eh bien merci à beaucoup
catherine de roche pour votre réaction
non merci
mais on a vu pendant votre interview que
le premier ministre edouard philippe
était arrivé pour la séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement qui va
démarrer d'ici une bonne dizaine de
minutes
alors les partis politiques se mettent
en ordre de marche pour les élections
européennes le parti l'est républicain
le votrient jérôme bascher a dévoilé sa
liste pour le scrutin du 26 mai prochain
30 noms et forcément des déçus dont
certains vont quitter le parti
les explications de les adopter
une liste de candidats est un exercice
d'équilibriste pour laurent wauquiez
les noms devaient figurer par ordre
alphabétique sans classement mais l'idée
critiqué par gérard larcher et bruno
retailleau est abandonnée en tête
françois xavier bellamy anja c'est vrai
mais arnaud danjean derrière eux des
proches de nicolas sarkozy les députés
sortants nadine morano et brice
hortefeux autre proche de l'ancien
président frédéric péchenard parmi les
nouveaux candidats
à ses côtés des soutiens du patron du
parti laurent wauquiez lydia guirous ce
laurent ça y est et deux places pour les
centristes d'hervé morin grande absente
rachida dati qui a annoncé briguer la
mairie de paris et michèle alliot-marie
eurodéputée sortante une liste
équilibrée selon le sénateur républicain
sébastien meurant
c'est une liste qui comprend des
sortants ont créé qui ont de
l'expérience puisqu'il faut d'un minimum
de continuité pour faire porter la voix
de la france en europe et une liste qui
fait la part belle à des jeunes talents
est incarnée notamment par une tête de
liste françois berry bellamy qui est une
liste de valeurs une liste qui défendra
fortement ses valeurs des choix qui ne
font pas l'unanimité
l'ex députée marie jo zimmermann et la
maire de morlaix agnès le brun ont
annoncé mercredi quitter les
républicains le sénateur françois noël
buffet appelle à l'union et il est
normal que ceux qui n'ont pas obtenu ce
qu'il souhaitait se sentent un peu en
difficulté soient mécontents
il faut sortir de cette polémique
maintenant les choses ont été décidées
par la commission nationale
d'investitures hier sur proposition du
président et des rapporteurs avançons et
mettons nous en route
la liste doit encore être validé par le
conseil national du parti
rendez vous pris le 16 mars à lyon les
élections gérant de ma chère cette liste
de 30 noms dévoilés finalement dans
l'ordre c'était pas prévu au départ
est-ce qui vous convient vous voit ce
qui me convient c'est que effectivement
on est donnée la vérité des prix c'est à
dire les noms dans l'ordre faut quand
même arrêter de se moquer du monde
commençait à faire des choses et dont je
suis très content que la voix de gérard
larcher de bruno retailleau et de leur
semble de nos collègues sénateurs nous
en avions parlé le matin
le mardi matin en rayon groupe semble
vouloir dire tout tous les tous nos
secrets d'alcôve ray pour les mecs faut
il faut il faut être clair enfin voilà
et puis que certains soient déçus c'est
une habitude
en tout cas quand on appartient à une
famille politique ont fait pas ça
uniquement pour des places ont fait ça
d'abord par des convictions
l'important c'est les convictions de
rassemblement moi je suis pour le
rassemblement et je trouve que le trio
de tête qui a été choisie est une bonne
idée
on peut toujours dire il aurait mieux
fallu mettre un tel un tep
c'est très difficile de faire une liste
ou ceux qui s'ils ont conduit une liste
on fait une liste une fois dans leur vie
savent combien c'est difficile faut
jeter la première pierre
françoise cartron ou à la république en
marche on n'a pas encore la tête de
liste mais on a le projet du président
emmanuel macron la renaissance
européenne
et oui eh ben je crois que c'est par là
qu'il faut commencer las avant de mettre
des noms faut savoir pourquoi on y va et
qu'est-ce qu'on veut défendre et il me
semble que et il ya des prix vous
défendez le discours de la sorbonne où
le discours qui est ressorti à 3 jours
et non non je défends alors je vais vous
dire un les deux parce que bah oui c'est
le en même temps c'est tout et son
contraire mais non non c'est pas tout et
son contraire c'est une ligne à la
sorbonne le président marc courdes non
mais le président ma cran s'est affirmée
très engagée pour l'europe
c'était nouveau parce que jusque là tous
les candidats à la présidentielle ne
mettait pas l'europe comme premier
combat et c'était plutôt mal vu le
président et c'était pas forcément
populaire le président macro apporter
dès le début l'europe
bon on est content première de fait
alors mais non il continue dans la
lignée
enfin j'ai pas pensé il n'a pas été
battu que je sache alors il a été élu
dans l'union européenne vous trouver
at-il et lavez le persil a gagné le
combat non mais moi je vais pas
polémiquer avez-vous sur les ailes r on
en a pas fini autrement donc je parle de
prison n'aurait plus la cohérence de la
cohérence du président la république
dont il affirmé l'europe d'entrées dès
qu'il a été candidat il a été élu il a
poursuivi aujourd'hui il fait une lettre
qui s'adresse qui met un peu le cadre et
qui définit les grandes priorités la
sorbonne
avec la verve du cadre de la semaine je
ne pense pas que ça soit laid mais si
vous n'avez pas lu relise le oui mais
vous non plus vous l'avez pas lu parce
qu'un qui parle de renaissance c'est
bien l'esprit de la sorbonne l'europe
doit se retrouver les doigts l'europe
doit renaître
l'europe doit avoir une nouvelle
ambition donc là arriver à dire tout et
son groupe à moi je vais vous dire dans
le genre tout et son contraire vous vous
avez été excellent parce que moi j'ai
entendu bellamy dire faut surtout pas
d'ordre pour motiver tout le monde parce
que s'ils savent qu'ils sont à la place
et lui ils vont pas se battre et puis
deux jours après il ya le contraire
allez tout le monde d'un ordre
bon ça prépare le combat pour 7 pour ces
personnes rapidement les centristes
partent en ordre dispersé le modem et
agir avec en marche
hervé morin et les centristes avec les
élèves et lui dit vous allez faire quoi
alors lui d y a toujours fait depuis le
début a marqué sa volonté d'être présent
sur les élections européennes et je
crois que jean christophe lagarde a
montré par son dynamisme depuis quelques
semaines et son discours qu'il était
bien l'héritier de le de l'europe et de
ses grands bâtisseurs de l'europe et je
pense que évidemment nous avons du
chemin pour progresser mais nous sommes
très combatif sur ce sujet on va
rejoindre thème traduit un qui est avec
alain joyandet le sénateur les
républicains oui alain joyandet est la
liste elle est rose européenne a donc
été connue hier et sont premiers effets
se sont déjà bien des démissions du
parti de marie jo zimmermann ou encore
d'agnès le brun qui disent ne plus se
reconnaître votre commentaire
les choses sont simples une décision
collective dans un mouvement
démocratique
beaucoup de gens autour de la table une
liste a été proposé un vote a été émis
cette liste ouf on est un mixte entre
deux nouveaux visages des gens
d'expérience des femmes des hommes
aucune liste n'est parfaite mais en tout
cas celle là il faut la soutenir et
faire campagne normaux sont très sévères
à parle de petits arrangements entre
amis de régression de toute nature oui
mais souvent vous savez les gens qui
sont mécontents sur le coup peuvent être
un peu excessif je comprends que les
cantons fait une liste nationale
national y ait beaucoup de gens qui ont
envie de faire partie de cette liste
nationale beaucoup de gens sont
candidats très peu sont élus puisque par
définition on sait très bien que le
nombre de places est limité
mais maintenant c'est la décision de
notre famille politique tous ceux qui se
reconnaissent dans notre famille
politique
même si c'est compliqué même si c'est
difficile il faut faire campagne
oui compliqué difficile vous pensez
encore que cette liste peut réussir son
pari on a l'impression qu'ils aient un
petit sursaut niveau des sondages pour
lr savez six mois avant une élection on
peut rien dire quelques mots avant comme
nous sans gants difficile on a encore
beaucoup de questions à se poser sont
nos concitoyens qui vont donner la
réponse est ce qu'ils vont d'abord se
déplacer en nombre pour aller voter ou
pas c'est qu'ils vont s'intéresser
véritablement à l'europe
je pense qu'il ya une chose fondamentale
c'est que la position des républicains
dans le cadre de cette campagne
européenne je pense que c'est la
meilleure parce que elle est unie
nationalistes comme certains extrêmes ni
européiste comme d'autres extrême elle
est pour l'europe mais une europe qui
protège une europe sérieuse l'europe des
nations l'europe que l'on n'aurait
jamais dû abandonner
donc c'est ça qui moi me motive au fond
c'est le projet des républicains est ce
qu'est ce qui vous motive aussi c'est
bien le fait qu'un nombre de vos amis
sarkozyste qui sont en bonne place dans
cette liste nadine morano brice
hortefeux frédéric péchenard ils sont
tous plutôt bien placé ou est-ce que
cette chose mais manquant sa dimension
est ce que c'est choquant qu'un certain
nombre de candidats
ami de nicolas sarkozy d'ailleurs amis
aussi de de laurent wauquiez d'autres
leaders politiques soit sur cette liste
je crois que cette liste on fond
rassemble assez bien les différentes
sensibilités de notre famille politique
et donc il faut il faut effectivement
après les polémiques il faut faire
campagne le plus vite possible
alain joyandet pour conclure une
question tout de même sur le fait que
jean pierre raffarin soutiennent la
liste de la république en marche de la
part de l'ex co fondateur de l'ump
ancien premier ministre ancien sénateur
est ce que vous le déplorez quoi je le
déplore parce que j'ai toujours bête on
peut toujours on peut ne pas être
d'accord sur tout mais c'est toujours
bête de quitter sa famille politique
mais c'est la liberté de chacun
en tout cas c'est une clarification
puisque bon il y avait une certaine
quand même un certain flou autour de la
position des uns et des autres que la
clarification se fasse à l'occasion de
cette élection que l'avenir
appartiennent à la nouvelle génération
que laurent wauquiez veut mettre en
place
au fond finalement c'est un mal pour un
bien il vient merci beaucoup alain
joyandet d'avoir répondu à mes questions
et nous allons tout de suite rejoindre
alexandre poussard dans l'hémicycle du
sénat alexandre pour connaître et bien
l'ordre du jour de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
hewitt avait ces questions vont être
consacrés dans une grande partie aux
droits des femmes puisque nous sommes à
la veille du 8 mars de la journée
internationale des droits des femmes et
la france fait partie des pays les mieux
classés au monde en termes de protection
de ces droits des femmes mais il ya
quelques points noirs et notamment en
termes de violence sexuelle et sexiste
chaque année plus de 80 mille femmes
sont victimes de viol et de tentative de
viol
parmi ces victimes seulement 10% porte
plainte et une plainte sur 10 finalement
abouti à une condamnation alors cette
journée de la femme c'est aussi
l'occasion de faire un premier bilan de
la loi du gouvernement contre les
violences sexuelles et sexistes une loi
portée par la ministre marlène schiappa
secrétaire d'état à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes à rich a pas qui
devrait être absente cet après midi de
cette séance de questions d'actualité et
marié ne sais pas qui a déjà publié
quelques chiffres sur sa loi cette loi
déjà donné lieu à 332 amende pour
outrage sexiste la france étant le
premier pays au monde
à a pénalisé le harcèlement de rue par
des amendes pouvant aller entre 90 et
750 euros
mais malgré cette loi seulement la
moitié des français fait confiance à la
justice et à la police pour régler ces
questions de violence sexuelle et
sexiste et puis sur ce thème des droits
des femmes et il y aura une question de
la sénatrice communiste
laurence cohen sur les inégalités
salariales entre les femmes et les
hommes
aujourd'hui en 2019 il y a en moyenne 25
% d'écart de salaire entre les femmes et
les hommes mais à travail et à
compétences égales
cet écart s'élève à 10% et puis autre
thème de ces questions d'actualité du
sénat au gouvernement
l'agression de deux surveillants
pénitentiaires de la prison de condé sur
sarthe une agression au couteau par un
détenu radicaliser et par sa compagne
une dizaine de prisons sont toujours
bloqués aujourd'hui en protestation
contre cette agression les syndicats de
surveillants pénitentiaires demande au
gouvernement une amélioration des
conditions de travail et de sécurité de
ces surveillants pénitentiaires et le
premier ministre edouard philippe a
reconnu hier qu'il y avait une
défaillance dans la fouille des
visiteurs de la prison de condé sur
sarthe alors la sénatrice centriste de
l'orne qui est concerné localement par
cette agression et par cette prison la
sénatrice nathalie goulet posera une
question sur la radicalisation dans les
prisons puisque le détenu auteurs de
cette agression s'était radicalisé en
détention et puis enfin un thème de
cette séance de questions la crise de
l'industrie en france avec trois
affaires qui préoccupe le gouvernement
la sphère ford la ferrasse covan et la
sphère alstom la cloche vient de sonner
ses débuts de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
verbal est adoptée sous les réserves
d'usagé monsieur le premier ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité du
gouvernement je vous rappelle que la
séance est retransmise en direct sur
public sénat sur le site internet du
sénat et sur facebook au nom du bureau
du sénat
j'appelle chacun de vous mes chers
collègues a observé au cours de nos
échanges
l'une des valeurs essentielles du sénat
le respect qu'il s'agisse du respect des
uns et des autres ou de celui des temps
de trappes 2 de travail j'allais dire
temps de parole la parole est à monsieur
thani mohamed soly pour le groupe la
république en marche pour deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur premier
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues
mardi dernier deux surveillants ont été
grièvement blessés par un détenu et sa
compagne dans une unité de vie familiale
de la maison centrale de condé sur
sarthe
nos pensées vont d'abord vers ces hommes
et vers leurs familles ils ont vécu dans
leur chair cette attaque que vous avez
vous même qualifié madame la garde des
sceaux d' attaque terroriste
il s'agit bien de cela au dollar comme
en témoignent les mouvements devant
certains établissements hier et ce matin
l'émotion est vive parmi les personnels
pénitentiaires
elle est bien sûr légitime à ces femmes
et à ces hommes qui derrière les murs de
nos prisons exercent au quotidien et
métier difficile mais connue de nos
concitoyens est surtout essentiel pour
la sécurité de notre pays je voudrais
exprimer la gratitude et le respect de
la représentation nationale depuis 18
mois le gouvernement a beaucoup agi pour
les personnels pénitentiaires
cette ambition se manifeste notamment
dans le projet de loi de programmation
et de réformes pour la justice que vous
avez défendu devant le parlement depuis
l'automne et qui porte à la fois des
moyens pour l'administration
pénitentiaire sur les quatre années à
venir une réforme du sens et de
l'efficacité des peines et des mesures
qui doivent permettre de renforcer la
sécurité des personnels de surveillance
et des établissements madame la ministre
au-delà de cet effort budgétaire qui est
nécessaire et de ces mesures
vous pouvez pouvez vous nous dire ce qui
a déjà été entrepris et surtout ce que
vous comptez faire pour améliorer encore
la sécurité de nos prisons merci la
parole est à madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
madame la présidente des dames et
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le président en swahili
il ya 48 heures je me suis effectivement
rendu au chevet des deux agents qui ont
été gravement blessées lors de l'attaqué
terroriste qui a eu lieu à condé sur
sarthe
je tiens à témoigner devant vous de leur
professionnalisme et du courage face à
une attaque d'une rare violence
nous devons leur rendre
maj ainsi qu'aux forces de sécurité qui
ont mis fin à cette attaque
une enquête judiciaire est en cours et
de mon côté j'ai saisi l'inspection
générale de la justice pour analyser les
conditions dans lesquelles cette attaque
a pu intervenir
condé sur sarthe est en effet un
établissement sécuritaire avec un
quartier de prise en charge de la
radicalisation ouverte depuis septembre
dernier les tables l'établissement peut
s'appuyer sur des personnels dont la
compétence est unanimement reconnue
c'est pour cela qu'il nous faut mieux
comprendre ce qui s'est passé
nous devons en effet je crois nous poser
des questions les procédures de fouilles
des visiteurs en particulier dans ces
établissements sécuritaires son talent
adapter les moyens techniques pour la
détection d'objets métalliques
peuvent-ils être améliorés renforcer les
éléments de dangerosité des détenus sont
ils bien pris en compte pour assurer
leur affectation notamment dans le cadre
de l'accès aux unités de vie familiale
depuis 18 mois vous l'avez rappelé notre
gouvernement a agi pour renforcer la
protection des personnels de
surveillance
nous avons en effet décidé de recruter
1100 personnel de surveillance
supplémentaires
nous avons renforcé les effectifs du
renseignement pénitentiaire
nous avons amélioré les équipements de
sécurité des surveillants pénitentiaires
une réorganisation de la sécurité
pénitentiaire de l'administration
centrale sera présenté dès la semaine
prochaine
soyez assurés que c'est une action
déterminée que nous conduisons en lien
avec les organisations syndicales que je
recevrai très prochainement à ce sujet
bien sûr j'entends les impatiences je
les comprends mais soyez sûrs que la
résolution du gouvernement est
absolument sans faille
parce que la sécurité de nos
établissements et nos personnels est une
condition qui n'est pas négociable et
nous y travaillons activement
monsieur mort est son édition était vous
répond merci
la parole est à madame maryse carrère
pour le groupe du rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation
mardi dernier le quotidien le quotidien
sud-ouest titré aides européennes pour
le secteur rural la france va-t-elle
perdre ses millions ces interrogations
cette interrogation fait suite au
constat de sous-consommation du fonds
leader se former depuis 1991 un
véritable moteur de développement
il apporte un soutien à l'innovation à
la mise en réseau et à la coopération
sur nos territoires ruraux
nous savons tous combien la constitution
d'un dossier pour demander d'efforts
leader peut être fastidieuse mais nous
savons aussi combien le versement
s'apparente à un véritable parcours du
combattant
en effet sur l'enveloppé initiale de 700
millions seuls 4 % auraient été versés
vous reconnaîtrez monsieur le ministre
qui nous faut mieux faire mieux faire
parce qu'à l'heure où l'on reproche trop
souvent à l'europe à l'europe d'être
éloigné de nos citoyens le programme
leader est un axe fort de son action au
bénéfice de nos territoires ruraux mieux
faire parce que derrière ces aides non
versées ce sont des artisans des
commerçants des acteurs sociaux et
culturels culturel et de nombreuses
communes qui sont fragilisés si des
progrès ont été récemment effectués par
l'état et qu'il arrive renforcer sa
mobilisation dans l'assistance des
régions qui ont je vous le rappelle
récupérer l'instruction des dossiers
quasiment du jour au lendemain
des doutes subsistent alors que le
président de lider france parle de crash
généralisée du programme que de trop
nombreux projets sont à l'arrêt
pouvez-nous monsieur le ministre nous
rassurer sur le versement des fonds
prévus pour la période 2014 2020 avant
le terme de celle-ci et enfin à l'heure
de la renégociation du cadre financier
pluriannuel 2021 et 2027
pouvez-nous nous rassurer sur le
maintien de l' enveloppe actuellement
octroyés dans le cadre du dispositif
dispositif leader je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur didier guillot
ministre de l'agriculture et de
l'alimentation
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et sénatrices
madame la sénatrice je ne veux
absolument pas vous rassurer parce que
la situation n'est pas rassurante
vous parlez des défend leader et vous
savez très bien comment les choses se
passent le programme leader c'est 7,5
millions d'euros attribuée à la france
pour que les fonds puissent être
attribués ils doivent passer par les
groupes d'action locaux légal ces
groupes d'action locaux sont en relation
avec les collectivités locales et
notamment les intercommunalités
intercommunautés elle même sur sa
relation avec les les régions or
aujourd'hui comme c'était le cas déjà
avant très peu de dossiers tous les
dossiers ont été présentés mais très peu
les dossiers sans apurer est donc grand
pu être payés et effectivement la france
c'est absolument un drame va perdre
plusieurs millions voire plusieurs
centaines de millions liées à l'europe
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas acceptable
c'est la raison pour laquelle il reste
encore quelques temps pour faire
accélérer ses dossiers depuis plusieurs
années maintenant ce sont les régions
qui font qu'ils sont là qui sont
responsables de ces projets c'est la
raison pour laquelle dans la future pac
et j'en ai parlé avec le président morin
avec les gens de france pour la future
pac
il faut absolument un des croisements
des aides totales une simplification et
une clarification
parce que si nous continuons comme cela
les mêmes causes produiront les mêmes
effets et les premiers projets ne seront
pas ne seront pas payés
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
sommes très attachés à ce que l'ensemble
de ces de cette puce est fait depuis
deux ans trois ans il ya des
associations des collectivités locales
qui ont eu des actes d'engagement et qui
ne sont toujours pas payés ce n'est pas
normal donc nous intervenons auprès de
l'europe pour que les choses puissent
accélérer et nous travaillons
constamment avec hervé morin et régions
de france afin d'essayer de voir comment
nous pourrions régler le problème de
façon plus plus rapide mais
malheureusement je crains madame la
sénatrice maryse carrère que je ne
puisse pas vous rassurer marfaing
essayons ensemble de faire en sorte que
les actions engagées par légale puissent
être payés dans le temps imparti je vous
remercie madame carrère il
reste quatorze secondes pour une réponse
oui merci monsieur le ministre même si
vous nous rassurer pages passe vraiment
sincèrement qu'il faut réfléchir à
simplification de ces fonds en réduisant
les échelons décisionnels et en donnant
davantage de pouvoirs aux régions elles
ont aujourd'hui une autorité de gestion
donnons-leur aujourd'hui d'autorité de
financement merci la parole est à madame
laurence cohen pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen et écologistes pour
deux minutes et un madame la présidente
à la veille du 8 mars journée
internationale de lutte pour les droits
des femmes les femmes n'ont toujours pas
obtenu l'égalité professionnelle qui
passe par un salaire égal à celui des
hommes pour un travail de valeur égale
26% - en moyenne en france
faut-il encore le rappeler pourtant leur
seul à l'arsenal législatif existe pour
parvenir à l'égalité professionnelle
tout récemment les mobilisations des
femmes des associations féministes et
des organisations syndicales unies ont
permis d'obtenir une avancée en matière
d'égalité salariale avec la mise en
place d'une obligation de résultats pour
les entreprises
la ministérielle pénicaud ya contribué
comme elle s'y était engagée ici même
lors de l'examen de la loi liberté de
choisir son avenir professionnel
hélas dispositions après disposition le
décret vide de son efficacité le
dispositif que nous avions voté en
juillet dernier pourquoi avoir retenu
madame la ministre des modalités de
construction de cet index de l'égalité
salariale qui permet aux entreprises de
dissimuler écarts de rémunération allant
ainsi à l'encontre du pouvoir législatif
la parole est à madame agnès pannier rue
nash et secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
madame la présidente madame la sénatrice
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
l'avait bien dit les femmes représentent
50 % de la population active
elle ne contribue qu'à 37 % du pib sont
payés 9% deux mois à fonction égale et
26% - sur le temps d'une carrière
selon le women's forum au rythme actuel
il faudrait attendre 2234 pour atteindre
une parfaite parité
nous refaisons d'attendre deux siècles
c'est pour cette raison que la loi pour
la liberté de choisir son avenir
professionnel de septembre 2018 prévoit
désormais une oblique
sion de résultat et une transparence des
entreprises sur ces questions l'index
pour l'égalité professionnelle permet
cette transparence il a été élaboré avec
les partenaires sociaux comme vous le
savez a été unanimement saluée lors de
sa sortie
c'est index ne porte pas que sur
l'égalité salariale mais aussi sur les
chances de carrière et de promotion il
porte aussi sur la parentalité avec
l'item spécifique des congés maternité
il est exigeant puisque 118 entreprises
sur les 732 depuis 2000 salariés sont en
alerte rouge et quelque 600 on montre
des progrès à faire sur les premiers
résultats publiés
il est assorti d'une sanction qui peut
aller jusqu'à 1 % de la masse salariale
pour que les engagements pris par les
entreprises ne soient pas en chocolat
il est également propice à un dialogue
social dans l'entreprise puisqu'il
laisse un temps d'adaptation aux
entreprises pour converger vers une
parité parfaite
je crois que ces éléments témoignent de
l'engagement sans faille de l'ensemble
du gouvernement pour la parité hommes
femmes
je vais l'appuyer par les engagements
complémentaires qui ont été pris par un
certain nombre de sociétés changent pour
un certain nombre de sociétés
volontaires pour afficher le taux
d'encadrement taux de femmes à tous les
niveaux de l'entreprise et de s'engager
pour chaque poste d'encadrement a publié
une à avoir une candidate femme est une
candidate hommes ce qui est la meilleure
façon de nourrir le vivier est de
promouvoir les femmes dans l'entreprise
je vous remercie madame cohen vous avez
57 secondes pour une ré pour une madame
la ministre vous parler de sanctions
financières pour les entreprises
contrevenantes mais c'est de la poudre
aux yeux
en réalité vous avez choisi des
indicateurs qui rendent invisibles et
discrimination est quasi inopérante les
sanctions que vous avez rendu de fait
exceptionnel pire vous avez même
introduit un seuil de tolérance de
violation de la loi les femmes qui
manifestent dans la rue depuis des mois
pour obtenir plus de pouvoir d'achat en
exigeant notamment une hausse des
salaires et des minima sociaux ne
peuvent se satisfaire d'un ter tour de
passe passe comme les organisations
syndicales les associations féministes
qui dénoncent la précarité le recours au
temps partiel imposé et demandent la
revalorisation des métiers de
prédominance féminine
je serai dans la
à leurs côtés demain à 15h40 heure
symbolique pour dénoncer le travail
gratuit effectués quotidiennement par
les femmes
à l'heure où le gouvernement cherche des
financements effet la poche des pauvres
l'égalité salariale reprend porterait
selon la fondation concorde 62 milliards
d'euros mais cher collègue à l'économie
française
alors madame la ministre
qu'attendez-vous pas de belles paroles
des actes la parole est à madame corinne
ne ferrait pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
merci madame la présidente mes chers
collègues ma question était destiné à
madame la ministre du travail mais je
vois que c'est madame darrieussecq qui
va y répondre
madame la ministre la crise sociale
profonde qui traverse notre pays ces
derniers mois jette une lumière crue sur
l'ampleur et l'aggravation des
inégalités dans notre société et il
suffit d'observer les cortèges qui
défilent dans les rues pour constater
que les femmes sont particulièrement
frappés par cette précarité
en cette veille du 8 mars journée
internationale des femmes
il est impossible de ne pas s'indigner
que l'égalité des chances tant
recherchée ne s'opère pas avec la même
force que l'eau soit un homme ou une
femme
et les chiffres sont têtus même
implacable cela a été dit mais c'est
bien de le répéter aujourd'hui en france
à poste égal une femme touchera en
moyenne 9 % de salaire de moins qu'un
homme
dans l'ensemble de sa carrière son
salaire sera moins 25 % inférieur à
celui d'un homme
nous sommes je le sais est unanime pour
condamner une telle inégalité
mais où sont les actes madame la
ministre vous avez créé un index de
l'égalité femmes/hommes attribués aux
entreprises de plus de 1000 salariés une
note
si l'intention est louable nous ne
pouvons que regretter le manque
d'ambition de cette mesure
pourquoi en effet la limiter aux grandes
entreprises quand plus de 48 % de
l'emploi salarié se trouve dans les pme
mais surtout comment courant cet
indicateur si les entreprises s'évaluer
de même et quant au 1er mars
seule la moitié des entreprises s'est
plié à cette obligation
l'indispensable lutte contre les
inégalités ne peut se réduire à un
tableau de chiffres
elle doit passer par une politique
volontariste et coercitives sanctionnant
les discriminations avec la plus grande
sévérité
nous ne pouvons plus accepter comme le
démontre une étude publiée par votre
ministère l'année dernière que 62 % des
femmes ont connu et connaîtront la
précarité professionnelle au cours de
leur carrière contre seulement 32% des
hommes
madame la ministre alors que le
président de la république a déclaré que
l'égalité entre les femmes et des hommes
devaient être composé entre autres de
son capitanat
quelle est la réalité la vérité c'est
que le budget consacré à cette lutte ne
représente que 80 millions d'euros il
faudra 000 66 % du budget ma question
est donc simple
quelles mesures comptez-vous prendre
enfin pour être à la hauteur des
engagements pris devant la nation
la parole est à madame geneviève
darrieussecq secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des armées
merci madame la présidente mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
vous l'avez dit oui les choses sont
préoccupantes
les femmes sont les premières victimes
de la pauvreté
du travail partiel subi des métiers sous
payés des inégalités salariales
ce sont les mères isolées qui souvent
sont en grande difficulté
les petites retraites également on les a
entendues partout en france et notamment
sur les ronds points
c'est un constat et oui la grande cause
nationale de ce quinquennat c'est
l'égalité hommes-femmes et oui nous
faisons tout pour agir dans ce domaine
où nous avons à mon sens dans ce pays
pris beaucoup de retard
nous agissons pour créer les conditions
d'accès de réussite des femmes au même
titre que les hommes bien sûr mixité des
filières avec notamment la fondation
france numérique égalité salariale on
vient d'en parler avec agnès pannier qui
a développé le sujet dans le pv mais
également dans le public avec la
création d'un fonds en faveur de
l'égalité professionnelle dans la
fonction publique qui a été lancé il ya
quelques jours par olivier du sorte del
entendu cela passe aussi par un travail
important sur la conciliation entre vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle
les congés de maternité améliorer
l'évolution des modes de garde d'enfants
la transparence dans l'attribution des
places en crèche
ça passe également par l'entrepreneuriat
au féminin avec le réseau des
ambassadrices de l'entrepreneuriat le
gouvernement engagé les banques à mieux
financer les entrepreneurs
les nominations paritaire et j'ai écrit
il a été envoyé un courrier en ce sens à
tous le gouvernement afin de travailler
sur ce sujet et puis bien sûr nous
devons vaincre le sexisme et les
violences sexuelles et sexistes qui
gangrène tous les milieux alors c'est un
combat culturel
c'est un combat culturel il nous faut
mener à tous les niveaux leur est
notamment démarré par le niveau de
l'éducation
je crois que c'est un combat que nous
mènerons tous ensemble
la parole est à monsieur jérôme bignon
pour le groupe les indépendants
république et territoires pour deux
minutes
merci madame la présidente le président
macron l'a affirmé au salon de
l'agriculture l'europe doit avoir une
politique agricole basée sur trois
piliers forts protéger transformer
anticipé le groupe allemand sud du caire
en restructurant son outil industriel
saint louis sucre en france enfermement
en fermant et peuvent ils dans la somme
met en cause le pilier protection et le
pilier anticipation pas le moindre
préavis
pas la moindre concertation heureusement
que la france et l'allemagne sont
étroitement unie par différents traités
de coopération
le dernier signe à aix la chapelle
heureusement que la pac existe depuis le
traité de rome
qu'en serait-il autrement à la veille
des élections européennes
ce capitalisme débridé n'illustre pas de
façon positive la coopération pourtant
ce pourtant souvent ventés entre nos
deux pays
cette décision si elle devient effective
condamne d'importants bassins de
production de betteraves dans la somme
pas seulement dans l'aisne dans l'oise
dans le pas de calais dégrade 1275
exploitations agricoles soit plus de 20
mille hectares tout l'écosystème local
avec plus de 600 emplois directs et
indirects et déstabilisé et remis en
cause et salariés de l'usiné les
transporteurs les sous-traitants les
commerces locaux
les entrepreneurs agricoles sont
violemment impactés il s'agit
aujourd'hui de préserver l'intégrité
d'une filière française qui contribuent
chaque année pour 1,3 milliard d'euros à
réduire le déficit de notre balance
commerciale
c'est impératif de s'y engager le
gouvernement doit tout mettre en oeuvre
pour éviter cette décision qui mettrait
en danger une filière performante
durement affecté par la fin des quotas
et la chute des prix
hardy vous avez dit monsieur le ministre
à l'assemblée que le sujet est grave et
qu'il fallait réagir
je suis d'accord avec vous vous avez dit
également négocié avec la commission
européenne et vous avez proposé aux
députés les associer aux réunions de
travail avec la filière le sénat
aimerait être associé à ces réunions
au même titre que l'assemblée nationale
pourriez-vous enfin nous dire si depuis
mardi ce dossier a pu avancer et quelles
sont les pistes ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur jérôme bignon la question que
vous posez une question grave grave pour
la filière sucrière et bat betteravière
de france même si je veux affirmer ici
que malgré ces décisions la filière
betteravière dans son ensemble n'est pas
en danger
elle pourra continuer à affirmer la
décision unilatérale dessous dessus
coeur de fermer trois sites où quasiment
de les fermer est absolument
inacceptable
cani dans calvados concerne 1100
planteurs 85 emplois directs supprimés
et peuvent ils dans la somme 1400
planteurs centre de 132 emplois directs
supprimés 122 seraient transférés et à
marseille 58 salariés dont 5 seulement
seraient seraient maintenus nous avons
donc travaillé avec l'ensemble des 2 de
la filière les réunions sont tenues avec
l'ensemble des coopératives
cet après midi à 17 heures au ministère
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
l'ensemble des parlementaires concernés
sur tous les bancs sont invités pour une
réunion de concertation
parce que je veux jouer la transparence
la plus totale parce que dans une
opération comme celle là c'est par la
transparence ça en nous serrant les
coudes en travaillant avec les acteurs
de la filière que nous y arriverons vous
avez été plusieurs à m'interpeller
directement vous même monsieur le
sénateur daniel dubois corinne féret ça
m'est égal y est et d'autre et je crois
que nous devons avancer dans une botte
dans une seule et même direction
aujourd'hui nous devons affirmer que
nous ne pouvons pas laisser faire les
choses en l'état la semaine prochaine
avec mon collègue bruno le maire
nous allons rencontrer la direction et
le président dessus du coeur afin de
regarder vraiment quelles sont les
intentions de cette coopérative
je rappelle que ces 17% de la filière
betteravière qui est qui est concerné et
nous voulons aller plus loin il est
question de réorientation de
réorganisation de cette filière
nous travaillons avec le président et
l'ensemble de la filière sucrière
la situation est grave mais elle est
prise en compte par vous même je le sais
monsieur bignon par l'ensemble des
sénateurs ici pour l'ensemble des
parlementaires et le gouvernement sera
au rendez vous pour accompagner la
filière pour grand peiné par les
parlementaires
et pour négocier avec l'entreprise ou de
soccer je remercie monsieur mignon pour
8 secondes
ces dix pour ça on enlève la présente ce
capitalisme sauvage entre états membres
ces intérêts court termiste ces
distorsions de concurrence ces usages
des voiliers de l'argent public ne sont
pas acceptables dans un marché unique
européen
ce non respect des planteurs et des
travailleurs n'est pas acceptable
néanmoins merci monsieur milices pour
votre réponse la parole est à m e jean
jacques panunzi pour le groupe l'est
républicain
merci madame la présidente
ma question s'adresse à madame la
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
et des relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
madame la ministre la corse a été le
premier territoire français à se doter
d'une paix peut en 2015 elles avaient
fait l'objet de jets travail de
convergence d'un vote à l'assemblée de
corse et d'un décret ministériel 7 pp
permettait d'appréhender les prospective
énergétique de la corse en misant sur
une vraie politique d'efficacité
énergétique une meilleure intégration
des énergies renouvelables dans le mix
énergétique tout en prenant en compte la
vétusté de certains moyens de près du
production comme la centrale du vazzio
interconnexion entre la corse et
l'italie
aujourd'hui nous constatons que cette
paix peut unanimement saluée au niveau
national comme local mans qui avait
obtenu toutes les validations des
différentes commissions nationales et
qui avait réussi à obtenir l'accord de
la majorité des parties prenantes en
corse semble être remise en question
j'en veux pour preuve la lettre envoyée
à la collectivité de corse par nicolas
hulot alors ministre de la transition
écologique et solidaire envoyé juste
avant sa démission ainsi que les
commentaires des uns et des autres dans
les médias
suite à la dernière rencontre que vous
avez eue avec l'exécutif régional
madame la ministre pourriez vous nous
faire savoir quelles sont les intentions
du gouvernement concernant la prochaine
pp en corse notamment au regard des
éléments majeurs présents dans
l'actuelle ppe sachant qu'il y a urgence
et que les corses n'accepterons jamais
une prolongation des anciens moyens de
production qui doivent normalement être
déclassées en 2023 notamment l'actuel
central du vase ou qui est un outil
vieillissant sujet de nombreux incidents
et fonctionnant actuellement au fioul
lourd aller au delà de 2023 avec de tels
outils mettrait à l'évidence en risque
l'alimentation de la corse et
impliquerait de poursuivre un
fonctionnement fut lourd ce qui est
inacceptable
table pour la population du pays
ajaccien plus précisément madame la
ministre
pouvez vous nous dire si oui ou non le
gouvernement a l'intention de respecter
le décret du 10 décembre 2015 relatif à
la programmation pluriannuelle de
l'énergie en corse qui prévoyait la
réalisation d'une infrastructure
d'alimentation en gaz naturel de la
corse
l'exclusion avec un objectif de mise en
service au plus tard depuis 2000 23
ainsi que comme l'idée d'une puissance
de 250 mégawatts et la conversion des
moyens techniques existent dans le gaz
naturel
je vous remettre la parole est à madame
jacqueline gourault ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur panunzi la corse fait l'objet
comme vous venez de le rappeler du fait
de son insularité d'une programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie à part et
d'une attention particulière du
gouvernement pour la sécurité de ses
approvisionnements énergétiques
aujourd'hui vous l'avez rappelé un tiers
de son électricité provient de centrales
thermique à fuel située à ajaccio et à
bastia qui sont vieillissantes et
polluantes
la ppe de 2015 a prévu que ces
installations seraient remplacées par
des centrales à gaz
à cet effet un projet consistait à
installer une barge de gaz à bastia et
de relier cette dernière par un gazoduc
traversant la corse jusqu'à ajaccio pour
alimenter la deuxième centrale
les difficultés sont son nom cependant
très nombreuses comme vous le savez
monsieur le sénateur en particulier
parce que le trajet du gazoduc doit
passer non seulement au travers de la
montagne mais aux milliers de parcelles
privées au régime particulièrement
complexe en corse comme vous le savez
nous avons
quand je dis nous c'est bien sûr le
ministre d'état ministre de l'écologie
et de la transition de la transition
écologique et solidaire pardon a reçu
très récemment et j'ai été présente à ce
rendez vous le président simeone et nous
avons exprimé à cet effet les doutes sur
la faisabilité de ce projet du gazoduc
et envisager de nouvelles pistes qui
pourraient passer par là l'installation
d'un second terminal de gaz
potentiellement immergé en mer au large
d'ajaccio
le gouvernement est résolu à tenir ses
engagements dans la nouvelle ppe et bien
sûr veut s'assurer du renforcement de la
sécurité énergétique de la corse tout en
développant les énergies renouvelables
la parole est à madame annick billon
pour le groupe union centriste
merci madame la trêve
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à la
secrétaire d'état en charge de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes et de la
lutte contre les discriminations en
novembre 2010 est le prénom ce président
annonçait vouloir faire de l'égalité
entre les hommes et des femmes
la grande cause nationale de son
quinquennat et en cette veille du 8 mars
je souhaiterais évoqué la question
alarmante des féminicides le taux de
femmes tuées s'accélère de façon
inquiétante depuis le début de cette
année en effet depuis janvier 2019 30
femmes ont été tuées par leur conjoint
ou ex conjoint
c'est deux fois plus que l'année
précédente à la même période elles sont
plus de 200 avoir succombé ces dernières
années plus généralement environ 225
mille femmes sont victimes de violences
conjugales physiques ou sexuelles en
2018 dans le sillage de l'affairé wayne
stein les plaintes pour viol augmenté de
près de 17% et celle pour agression
sexuelle ont bondi de 20%
or le nombre de condamnations effectives
lui stagne on le sait la formation des
personnels de police sur ces questions
dans est qu'à ses balbutiements
par ailleurs la délivrance de ordonnance
de protection pour les juges aux
affaires familiales en principe
accessibles à toutes les victimes de
violence conjugale sans nécessiter des
dépôts de plainte préalable est loin
d'être systématique la lutte contre les
violences conjugales doit être
appréhendée de manière globale en
incluant les individus les travailleurs
sociaux les magistrats les forces de
l'ordre les associations selon le haché
seuls 80 millions d'euros des crédits
sur les 420 millions pour l'égalité sont
alloués chaque année à la lutte contre
les violences faites aux femmes
il faudrait cinq fois plus de moyens car
la mise en place de politiques publiques
à réel impact sur la hausse ou la baisse
du nombre de victimes
c'est pourquoi je vous pose la question
à la veille de cette journée hautement
symbolique
le gouvernement se donne t'il réellement
les moyens de lutter contre les
féminicides je vous remercie
la parole est à madame agnès plus d'un
ministre des solidarités et de la santé
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs des sénateurs madame la
sénatrice pardon madame la présidente
annick billon veuillez pardonner
l'absence de ma collègue la ministre
omanais n'y a pas je vais répondre à sa
place concernant l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes
vous le savez c'est la grande pause du
quinquennat et nous avons pris un
certain nombre de mesures depuis notre
arrivée puisque c'est une s'agit d'une
politique largement interministérielle
qui est porté de façon volontariste par
l'ensemble des membres du gouvernement
plus de cent mesures concrètes ont déjà
été prises
j'en citerai quelques unes et vous le
savez les moyens financiers sont
conséquents puisque 3 530 millions
d'euros ont été inscrits au plf 2010 9
donc c'est un budget
important je crois le plus important
jamais dédiée à cette cause de l'égalité
entre les femmes et des hommes vous le
savez la lch a peint dans sa loi portait
la création du délit d' outrage sexistes
permettant de verbaliser le harcèlement
de rue et nous sommes le premier pays au
monde à mettre en oeuvre cette mesure
cela fonctionne en six mois plus de 330
amendes ont été infligées allant jusqu'à
750 euros et ce dispositif fera l'objet
d'une évaluation parlementaire à partir
du début de l'été ce qui permettra de
proposer d'éventuelles correctifs par
ailleurs je pense aussi à la loi portée
par muriel pénicaud sur l'égalité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
mais vous m'interrogez sur les violences
faites aux femmes sur les féminicides
nous sommes engagés très rapidement sur
la création de centres de prise en
charge du psycho traumatismes notamment
dédié aux femmes victimes de violences
sexuelles est fictive de victimes de
violence tout court de leur conjoint
nous avons fait un appel à projet n'a
pas la candidature l'année dernière ces
dix centres ont été créés labellisés
nous sommes le premier pays au monde à
organiser des réseaux de prise en charge
des victimes de psycho traumatisme c'est
une mesure emblématique sur lequel il
avait un engagement du président de la
république lors du lancement de novembre
2017 et donc le gouvernement est
totalement mobilisée pour réduire
évidemment les violences faites aux
femmes je vous remercie
la parole est à madame josiane cost pour
le groupe du rassemblement démocratique
et social européen
merci madame la présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre des
transports madame la ministre
comme vous le savez le groupe rds est
très préoccupé par les questions de
mobilité et la nécessité d'agir
efficacement pour améliorer la desserte
des territoires fragiles est victime
d'un emploi d'un enlèvement mortifère
souvent à la fois routier ferroviaire et
aérien et même numérique
le sénat a voté le 20 février 2019 par
305 voix
la proposition de loi du rds relative à
ce sujet capital pour ces territoires et
nous attendons avec espoir que la loi
mobilité
prennent en grande partie ces
propositions largement partagé un des
sujets abordés par la proposition de loi
et le transport aérien régional et en
particulier les lignes d'aménagement du
territoire
certes vous avez prévu un effort
budgétaire et nous le salut en méforme
et sur le terrain force est de constater
que la qualité de plus en plus
déplorable du service rendu aux usagers
annulation fréquentes retard mettant
parfois en jeu leur sécurité
et ce en dépit du prix prohibitifs des
billets et du film financement public
etat collectivités de constater le quasi
monopole d'une compagnie nationale pour
laquelle ces liaisons sont
malheureusement considérées comme
secondaires voire comme une charge
il n'est pas concevable qu'en 2019 que
nos potes nos compatriotes habitant dans
ces territoires particulièrement
fragiles soient traités de la sorte
madame la ministre de questions simples
prendrez-vous en considération au cours
du débat sur la loi l'homme le contenu
de la proposition de loi votée par le
sénat
au delà des efforts financiers que nous
saluons quelle mesure entendez vous
mettre en place pour que les lignes
aériennes d'aménagement du territoire
permettent aux voyageurs de bénéficier
d'un prix et d'une qualité de service
digne de ce nom
la parole est à madame elisabeth bornes
ministre chargé des transports
le même la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice josiane cost j'ai eu
l'occasion de le dire lors de l'examen
du texte je partage largement les
constats de la proposition de loi est la
loi d'orientation des mobilités y
répondra concernant les liaisons
aériennes d'aménagement du territoire je
suis convaincu qu elles sont
essentielles pour nos territoires
c'est pour ça que j'ai souhaité relancer
ses liaisons en quadruplant le budget
qui leur est consacré et dès 2019
l'augmentation de ce budget va se
traduire par des améliorations concrètes
à limoges castres quimper poitiers et la
rochelle
nous n'avons donc pas attendu pour agir
et au delà de cet engagement de l'état
il est effectivement primordial de
redresser la qualité de service
ces dessertes et nous sommes fortement
mobilisée pour cela il y a plusieurs
mois j'ai demandé un programme d'actions
à hope qui a permis notamment de réduire
le nombre d'incidents techniques et donc
le nombre d'annulations et j'ai échangé
avec le nouveau directeur général d'air
france klm avec la nouvelle directrice
générale d'air france qui sont
pleinement conscients de la nécessité
d'améliorer la qualité de service sur
ces liaisons
ainsi l'organisation et la gestion des
vols va être repris directement par air
france et les appareils de type atr vont
être retirés de la flotte en 2020 au
demeurant ces liaisons sont remises
régulièrement en concurrence et on peut
donc espérer que ce soit l'occasion
d'améliorer la qualité de service donc
je peux vous assurer madame la sénatrice
que le gouvernement est pleinement
mobilisé pour assurer une meilleure
qualité de service sur cette liaison
essentielle pour nos territoires
madame cost il vous reste neuf secondes
merci madame la ministre pour votre
réponse les habitants de ces territoires
attendent vraiment une amélioration de
service les entreprises également parce
que nombre de rendez vous d'affaires son
manque est dû à des annulations ou des
retards et c'est absolument important
pour l'activité économique de nos de nos
territoires donc je vous remercie on
attend une amélioration avec impatience
merci la parole est à madame laurence
arrivée pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
en 2017 le gouvernement avait fait de la
réindustrialisation une priorité mais
les faits sont cruels 850 emplois rayés
de la carte chez ford 450 chez ask ovale
suspendus à des plans de reprise 750 à
la fonderie du poitou 900 sur les sites
sarthois papetier d'arjowiggins
la liste n'est pas close le gouvernement
a trouvé un digne l'attitude de ford et
s'est dit tromper dans la reprise
avortée d'arc ovale au delà de
l'indignation quelle est la colonne
vertébrale de la politique industrielle
pourquoi se désengager d'industries
stratégiques alors que d'autres font le
contraire des états unis à la chine
comme en europe
sur ce point les reproches envers les
pays bas vis-à-vis de air france klm
étonne au regard de l'énergie déployée
pour privatiser quelques fleurons
profitable à l'exemple des aéroports de
paris où est cette priorité à la reine
réindustrialisation madame le ministre
y at il une un état stratège la parole
est à madame agnès pannier rue nasser
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances madame la
présidente
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice
d'abord les faits sont têtus la france
la france crée aujourd'hui plus
d'emplois industriels qu'elle n'en
détruit la france ouvre à plus de sites
et en développe plus qu'elle n'en ferme
et cette situation est nouvelle depuis
deux ans car et oui
l'insee les statistiques les faits sont
têtus les chiffres aussi
et si je peux continuer depuis 20 ans
vous depuis 20 ans l'emploi industriel a
diminué de 1 million un million et
depuis deux ans il progresse et pourquoi
parce que nous avons mis en place une
politique industrielle ambitieuse
premièrement c'est une politique à 12
une politique industrielle qui permet le
développement de l'activité économique
en rendant la plateforme françaises plus
compétitives
c'est ça qui explique que toyota
investit 300 millions d'euros en france
daimler 500 millions d'euros en france
et que nous sommes désormais la première
destination des investissements directs
à l'étranger pour l'industrie une aide d
une politique industrielle qui développe
des contrats stratégiques de filières
pour 18 filières avec des projets
d'innovation des projets de compétences
et quel est le premier point de blocage
pour les emplois industriels
c'est le recrutement madame c'est ça qui
empêche la croissance 50 mille emplois
aujourd'hui ne sont pas pourvus dans
l'industrie deux cent mille si on était
capable de mettre les compétences face
aux chefs d'entreprise ça c'est la
réalité
alors oui il ya des guerres compères sur
ford sur blanquefort sur un sco valent
mais pourquoi vous ne parlez pas des
trois des 3000 emplois que nous avons
sauvé chez williams sauvera des emplois
que nous avons sauvé shaher industrie d
emplois que nous avons sauvé chez doux
trois entreprises sur quatre en
difficulté sont redresser grâce à
l'intensité de l'activité du
gouvernement
ça ce sont les faits madame
madame arrivé pour 57 secondes
madame la ministre soyons sérieux
peut-on réduire comme ça a été fait hier
par votre ministre une stratégie
industrielle au fait d'arracher 20
millions à un groupe qui en a touché 24
plus 500 millions de cic eux comme ce
fut le cas pour ford perd mais permettez
nous de vous proposer quelques pistes de
travail
osons des prises de participation
temporaire en cas de crise comme l'a
fait le président obama pour general
motors ou la france dans d'autres temps
pour peugeot
responsabilisons les grands groupes
donneurs d'ordre des pme s'ils renouent
pérennise ses commandes à la fonderie du
poitou la reprise devient crédible
appuyons nous sur les régions pour
ancrer au territoire innovation et
industrie du futur et les chiffres que
vous donnez sont en particulier le
résultat des politiques régionales
à l'image de la nouvelle aquitaine avec
usines du foot du futur qui a accompagné
près de 300 entreprises représentant 35
mille emplois en deux ans
osons la coopération induit
industrielles européennes à l'image
d'airbus en étant porteur d'une vision
européenne
voilà les pistes sur lesquelles nous
nous sommes prêts à travailler
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à madame céline voulait sp
rognés pour le groupe l'est républicain
madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le premier ministre
le hashtag prisonnière du hidjab
fleurissent sur les réseaux sociaux de
l'autre côté de la méditerranée derrière
il ya des femmes courageuses qui dénonce
le voile comme un instrument
d'oppression
elle pointe du doigt la pression sociale
et l'environnement familial qui les
condamne à se voiler
chez nous aussi la pression des
quartiers des familles ne l'est en
réalité que peu de choix aux femmes
voilées en particulier aux plus jeunes
d'entre elles alors que les femmes
algériennes nous indique la voie du
courage
la position de votre majorité est sur ce
sujet d'une ambiguïté problématique
or la france nation des droits de
l'homme doit véhiculer un message de
liberté pour les femmes du monde entier
le président de la république le 16
avril 2018 déclaré que le voile n'était
pas conforme à la civilité qu'il ya dans
notre pays le 28 février dernier il se
muer en défenseur du voile expliquant
que les entreprises qui discriminent les
femmes voilées al embauche devait être
sévèrement sanctionnés sur ce sujet
l'exécutif est donc preuve d'angélisme
pire de contradictions pouvez-vous au
nom du gouvernement devant notre
assemblée condamné à nouveau les propos
d'un député de votre majorité qui a
réalisé la semaine dernière un amalgame
sur réaliste entre le port du hidjab et
celui du serre tête alors que ce célèbre
demain la journée de la femme il est
essentiel de rappeler que le combat pour
une véritable égalité homme femme passe
aussi par le combat sur notre territoire
de toute forme de fondamentalisme dont
le voile est souvent un étendard
monsieur le premier ministre
le voile est il oui ou non un instrument
d'oppression des femmes et que comptez
vous faire pour protéger toutes ces
femmes qui sur le territoire français
sont contraintes de le porter je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame geneviève
darrieussecq secrétaire d'état auprès de
la ministre des armées
merci madame la présidente madame la
sénatrice
je rappellerai simplement que nous
sommes dans un pays où la laïcité est la
règle et la laïcité s'inscrit au fronton
de toutes nos mairies et au fronton de
toutes nos institutions
je crois que nous devons respecter
également la volonté de chacun de porter
ou non les attributs vestimentaires
qu'il souhaite porter dans l'espace
public
je dis bien dans l'espace public
pour le reste moi je préférerais que
nous nous dirigions vers ce que nous
mettons en oeuvre au niveau de ce
gouvernement c'est à dire une vraie
diplomatie féministe afin que nous
puissions partager nos convictions avec
de façon universelle sur les violences
faites aux femmes sur les contraintes
faites aux femmes sur l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes sur
l'émancipation des femmes qui sont des
concepts qui à notre sens doivent être
des concepts universels et qui nécessite
un engagement de toutes et tous
je crois sur le plan national et sur le
plan international
et c'est dans ce sens que marlène
schiappa de travail
c'est dans ce sens également que le
président de la république remettra le
prix simone veil qui récompense les
actions en faveur des droits des femmes
dans le monde et c'est dans ce sens
également que sera travaillé au niveau
de la présidence du g7 l'égalité entre
les hommes et les femmes parce que ce
dont vous me parlez madame c'est une
question d'égalité entre les hommes et
les femmes et pour nous cela est
absolument essentiel mais je le rappelle
cela doit s'inscrire dans notre pays
dans un esprit de laïcité qui est la
règle en france dans notre république
française
merci madame boulet ce fermier pour
quelques petites secondes
madame la ministre je prends acte de
votre réponse j'ai bien peur qu'elle
soit en total décalage avec le sens de
mon message
vous devez vous devez réaffirmer les
valeurs d'universalisme qui font l'adn
de la france vous devez nommer les
problèmes pour mieux les combattre et le
relativisme qui fait l'apanage de votre
gouvernance depuis le départ est une
mauvaise réponse à de vrais problèmes je
vous demande d'y réfléchir
il est temps il est temps vraiment la
parole est à madame nathalie goulet pour
le groupe union centriste
oui maintenant présidente là messieurs
les ministres mes chers amis chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
bello bg bien entendu la question de
notre collègue mohamed soilihi j'ai
aussi madame la garde des sceaux entendu
votre réponse pardonnez-moi si en tant
que sénateur de l'orne je n'ai pas
exactement la même vision de la
situation
évidemment je m'associe à la solidarité
qui a été exprimée à l'égard des
victimes de cet attentat
mais je veux dire que nous sommes entre
colère et découragement comprendre
l'improbable et surréaliste régime des
fouilles
alors que plus de 90 mille objets madame
la garde des sceaux a été trouvé cette
année quarante mille téléphones sont
entrés dans les prisons en 2017 orient
ne parle même pas de la créativité des
détenus a créé des armes par destination
avec tout ce qui leur passe par la main
sans compter que nous n'avons toujours
pas de gilet par l'âme pour les gardiens
et le personnel pénitentiaire comment
expliquer également l'accès à une unité
de vie familiale pour un criminel de
cette nature et j'ajoute deux fois par
mois
comment expliquer les failles du
renseignement pénitentiaire alors que ce
détenu était été signalé pour ces faits
de radicalisation mal à la ministre la
question que je voudrais vous poser
c'est quel calendrier et quelles mesures
avez-vous l'intention de prendre pour
que nos personnels pénitentiaires soient
mieux protégés qu'il n'est surtout pas
le sentiment que le confort des détenus
passent avant leur sécurité
la parole est à madame nicole belloubet
garde des sceaux ministre de la justice
madame la présidente mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice goulet je connais
votre réflexion sur la question de la
radicalisation j'ai d'ailleurs eu
l'occasion de lire ce que vous aviez
écrit hier et avant-hier sur ce sujet je
voudrais ici vous assurer que la
détermination du gouvernement pour
lutter contre la radicalisation en
prison est totale et je ne peux pas les
jeux ne peuvent pas vous laisser dire
des choses qui restent à l'encontre de
cette détermination je mets trois
arguments à l'appui de mon propos tout
d'abord nous avons agi pour prendre en
charge ces personnes radicaliser vous me
demandez un calendrier je vous le donne
depuis le mois d'octobre janvier dernier
nous avons développé des processus
d'évaluation de la radicalisation ils
sont en cours de déploiement nous avons
aujourd'hui cinq quartiers d'évaluation
de la radicalisation
là où il n'y en avait que de l'année
dernière nous avons ensuite mis en place
un système qui permet d'affecter ces
détenus radicaliser dans des lieux qui
sont adaptés ce sont des quartiers
d'isolement ou des quartiers de
prévention de la radicalisation tout
état de cause des quartiers étanche du
reste de la détention pour éviter le
prosélytisme mais cela se construit sur
le construit progressivement ensuite
nous avons et c'est le deuxième point
sur lequel je voudrais insister
nous avons renforcé la sécurité des
établissements
nous déployons un système de brouillage
nouveau des téléphones portables nous
commençons à le déployer à la prison de
la santé à vendin le vieil
et nous allons continuer nous avons un
dispositif de lutte contre les drones
nous avons accru de plus de 16% le
budget de sécurité des établissements
pénitentiaires et nous allons continuer
nous avons enfin pris des mesures c'est
le troisième point pour protéger nos
personnels pénitentiaires ces mesures de
protection contrairement à ce que vous
avez affirmé à l'instant passe notamment
par le déploiement d'équipements nouveau
gilet pare-balles tenu par coup plus de
1500 gillet par pardon par là mais
excusez moi pas par balles par l'âme
plus de 1500 gillet ont été déployés
cela doit continuer et il ya également
d'autres mesures qui sont prises dans ce
sens la sécurité des français et notre
priorité celles des personnels
pénitentiaires l'est tout autant madame
la sénatrice madame rouler bouler madame
la garde des sceaux je ne doute pas du
tout de votre détermination je sais
qu'il ya pas de baguette magique il n'ya
pas non plus de recettes parce que sinon
ça fait longtemps que le cdh à orelle
trouver des solutions nous avons été
très solidaire de l'ensemble des mesures
contre le terrorisme qui ont été votées
ces dernières années ce que je voulais
simplement indiqué c'est que la
radicalisation en prison ne date pas
d'hier elle ne date pas non plus de
votre gouvernement farhad khosrokhavar
l'a dénoncée depuis extrêmement
longtemps on sait qu'il faut du temps au
temps et ça c'est normal mais vous voyez
que les personnels ont comme manque
quand même d'équipement il manque aussi
de formation quant à l'évaluation qui
est un sujet majeur à la fois pour la
prévention mais aussi pour les gens qui
sont en prison veuillez croire que nous
nous cherchons des dispositifs qui
permettent cette évaluation qui est
absolument déterminante pour juger de la
dangerosité
surtout que nous allons avoir des
encombrants qui arrive de 100 go et
qu'on ne savons pas comment les traiter
la parole est à madame catherine dumas
pour le groupe l'est républicain
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères ministre de tutelle
d'atout france organisme en charge de la
promotion de la destination touristique
france à l'étranger
il semble en effet qu'une note interne
au quai d'orsay envisage un plan
d'économies drastique
atout france entraînant un plan social
de grande ampleur ayant pour conséquence
de réduire d'un tiers la masse salariale
également d'économiser près de 4
millions d'euros
l'opérateur business france d'ailleurs
seraient aussi concernés alors
évidemment nous ne sommes pas contre 2
nécessaires économies dans l' usage des
deniers publics bien au contraire
mais convenez monsieur le ministre que
cette coupe claire entraînerait la
fermeture de plusieurs bureaux à
l'étranger
quel impact aurait grandement les
missions de rayonnement d'attractivité
des destinations françaises dont atout
france a la charge
alors que notre pays subit depuis
plusieurs semaines une dégradation de
son image auprès des touristes étrangers
en raison des mouvements sociaux de
grande ampleur que nous subissons ma
question est simple
monsieur le ministre quelles sont vos
ambitions pour la promotion du tourisme
auprès des clientèles étrangères
la parole est à monsieur marc fesneau
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice d'humains le tourisme est un
secteur clé pour notre économie en même
temps qu'un instrument d' influence
majeure à l'étranger c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement fait du développement
touristique de l'ensemble des
destinations françaises l'une de ses
priorités
les objectifs que nous nous sommes fixés
en terme de fréquentation et de
retombées économiques sur les prochaines
années sont ambitieux à ce titre les
résultats de 2018 sont à cet égard
encourageants avec près de 90 millions
de touristes étrangers mais nous devons
encore faire davantage et atout france
est au coeur évidemment de cette
stratégie vous évoquer la question des
moyens
les grandes orientations données par le
gouvernement dans le cadre d'actions
publiques 2022 impliqueront
nécessairement et c'est logique une
transformation de la présence
internationale de l'état de ses opéras
l'heure est donc d'atout france en
évaluant l'efficacité de l'action de
chacun nous aurons donc très rapidement
rapidement amener à une réflexion
stratégique sur la manière meilleure
manière pardon d'utiliser la promotion
d'assurer la promotion touristique de
nos destinations à l'étranger avec atout
france et ses partenaires publics et
privés
mais en ce qui concerne plus
particulièrement le financement de la
promotion touristique
le gouvernement s'est clairement engagé
lors du conseil interministériel du
tourisme du 19 janvier dernier deal 2018
pardon en apportant des ressources
supplémentaires pérennes notamment par
le biais de la recette visa le ministre
jean yves le drian et le secrétaire
d'état jean baptiste lemoyne resteront
mobilisés pour que les collectivités les
professionnels et l'état rassemble leur
énergie et leurs moyens en faveur de la
promotion des destinations dans un
modèle partenarial qui caractérise notre
politique touristique et qu'incarne
atout france le gouvernement a également
conforté atout france dans sa mission
d'appui à la structuration de nos offres
touristiques
c'est le sens de la mise en place du
dispositif france tourisme a généré
porté par atout france et la banque des
territoires qui accompagne les
collectivités locales dans la
structuration de projets touristiques
d'envergure à même de répondre à une
demande mondiale toujours plus exigeante
c'est en effet en agissant à la fois sur
la demande et sur l'offre que nous
pourrons atteindre nos objectifs de
fréquentation et de recettes
touristiques et à faire mais plus encore
la vocation touristique de notre pays et
permettent que ce secteur soit l'un des
vecteurs de la croissance et de l'emploi
je vous remercie madame dumas pour 42
secondes
oui monsieur le ministre on j'ai bien
entendu votre réponse pourrait affirmer
votre ambition pour l'évolution du
tourisme dans notre pays je m'en réjouis
mais justement vous parlez du conseil
interministériel du tourisme j'en suis
membre
et c'est justement à cet effet que je
vous redis qu'un vaste plan social
atout france serait un paradoxe au
regard de l'objectif en quantité en
qualité que le gouvernement a fixé
également un paradoxe
aussi au regard de la concurrence de
plus en plus vives
d'autres destinations en europe et dans
le reste du monde
la parole est à monsieur stéphane
piennois pour le groupe les républicains
pour
minutes merci madame la présidente
madame la ministre après un début de
quinquennat exécuté à marche forcée nous
constatons tous ici un net
ralentissement de la marche depuis le 15
janvier
le temps législatif est figé et on ne
compte plus les projets de lois reporter
et les réformes suspendus aux
conclusions du grand débat national
plus grave sans doute encore le travail
parlementaire est désormais balayé d'un
revers de manche par votre gouvernement
ainsi le 11 décembre dernier le sénat a
voté à une très large majorité une
proposition de loi portée par notre
collègue françoise gatel rapportés par
agnès canayer proposition de loi qui
visait à apporter de la souplesse au
fonctionnement et à l'organisation des
communes nouvelles qui rappelons le
concerne 2 millions pas de deux millions
et demi de français dans 757 55 communes
nouvelles vous avez en tout cas le
gouvernement avait soutenu cette
démarche qui est particulièrement
attendu et notamment dans mon
département de maine et loire
hélas nous apprenons cette semaine que
l'examen de ce texte à l'assemblée
nationale qui était inscrit dans
l'agenda de l'assemblée nationale a été
reportée sine aidiez ce qui va à
l'encontre de votre à ganges engagement
madame la ministre
quelles garanties pouvaient pouvez vous
nous apportez pour que ce report ne soit
pas purement et simplement un d'amande
où la parole est à madame jacqueline
gourault ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations etc et
collectivités territoriales
madame la présidente monsieur le
sénateur vous avez rappelé l'importance
des communes nouvelles qui je le
rappelle ont été créées par la loi de
2010 et réformer en 2015 par le député
jacques pélissard cette politique est un
grand succès puisque aujourd'hui 2500
huit communes se sont regroupés pour
créer sept cent soixante quatorze
communes nouvelles
on peut féliciter dg d'ailleurs ne
serait-ce qu'en 2019 il y en a encore eu
239 en conséquence d'ailleurs le nombre
de communes et d'aujourd'hui de 34 1970
pour être très précise alors on sait
monsieur le sénateur que cette politique
a beaucoup de succès particulièrement
dans l'ouest de la france et notamment
dans le maine-et-loire que vous
représentez ici au sénat mais aussi dans
la manche
dans le calvados et dans l'eure pour
citer ceux qui arrivent en tête
vous me parlez alors bien sûr je ne
parle pas de l'accompagnement qui avait
été voté aussi financier etc
la proposition de loi adoptée
effectivement par votre haute assemblée
en décembre vise en ce sens à faciliter
le développement des communes nouvelles
et améliorées surtout les périodes
transitoires notamment ceux qui
concernent la composition des conseils
municipaux lire la deuxième période
ce texte a été reçue très positivement
il a été soutenu par le gouvernement
il est aujourd'hui bien sûr nécessaire
de d'envisager sa lecture mais il est
envisagé bien sûr à la lumière des
concertations menées actuellement avec
les maires dans le cadre du grand débat
à ce stade il a donc été décidé de
différer son examen monsieur
le sénateur et il ne faut pas toujours
voir le mal quelque part chez pieds
noirs pour 39 secondes
madame la ministre on reproche souvent
au parlement sa lenteur dans la
confection de la loi mais aujourd'hui
c'est le gouvernement qui bloque selon
le gouvernement qui ne veut pas
comprendre qu'il ya urgence à légiférer
sur ce texte notamment à la proche des
futures élections municipales j'entends
bien à votre volonté affichée d'être à
l'écouté je m'en félicite
c'est un changement notable peut-être
pourriez-vous aller jusqu'à entendre la
volonté des parlementaires qui
travaillaient qu'ils se saisissent des
attentes des élus locaux en étroite
collaboration d'ailleurs avec
l'association des maires de france
pourriez peut-être pourriez-vous
collectivement dans votre gouvernement
consacré un peu moins de temps à
l'animation du show médiatique de votre
mentor et davantage à une meilleure
considération du travail des élus
nationaux peut-être pourriez-vous
peut-être pourriez-vous enfin tout ça ou
le monde respectez votre vos engagements
par rapport aux élus que nous sommes
je vous rappelle que les prochaines
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
auront lieu mardi 12 mars à 16h45 et
seront retransmis sur public sénat le
site internet du sénat et sur facebook
je vais suspendre la séance elle sera
reprise à 16h15 pour la proposition de
loi relative à la nationalisation des
sociétés concessionnaires d'autoroutes
et à l'affectation des dividendes à
l'agencé de financement des
infrastructures de transport de france
la séance est suspendue
et voilà pour ces questions d'actualité
du sénat au gouvernement il ya eu
beaucoup de questions sur les droits des
femmes à la veille du 8 mars la journée
internationale des droits des femmes et
la sénatrice les républicains céline
boulay sp rogner a dénoncé le laxisme du
gouvernement face au port du voile
islamique hidjab qui est selon elle
imposée à des milliers de femmes en
france la secrétaire d'état geneviève
darrieussecq a rappelé le principe de
laïcité de liberté de culte et le
respect de la volonté de chacun et puis
il a eu un échange fort autour de
l'agression de deux surveillants
pénitentiaires à la prison de
condé-sur-sarthe la sénatrice centriste
de l'orne nathalie goulet a dénoncé
l'échec du gouvernement pour protéger
les surveillants pénitentiaires et la
ministre de la justice nicole belloubet
lui a répondu en rappelant que le budget
de la sécurité des prisons avait
augmenté cette année de 16% et que les
surveillants pénitentiaires à led équipé
d'équipements nouveaux notamment de
gilets par l'âme pour être mieux
protégés voilà jérôme pour les moments
forts de ces questions d'actualité du
sénat au gouvernement
merci beaucoup alexandre et on va tout
de suite prendre la direction de la
salle des conférences du sénat puisque
tam tran huy vous êtes avec la ministre
chargée des transports
elisabeth bornes et nous allons parler
ensemble du projet de loi mobilité le
projet de loi à l'homme madame board
et bien tout d'abord un certain nombre
de sénateurs sont inquiets sur ce projet
de loi pour eux il manque toujours 500
millions d'euros il pose toujours cette
même question du financement que la
répondez-vous pour les rassurer
alors écoutez je pense qu'il faut pas
réduire ce projet de loi à ce débat ce
n'est pas une loi de finances et moi je
me réjouis que la commission et puis
adopté hier le texte
je pense de façon très large ce qui
montre que on a eu un travail de qualité
en amont avec les sénateurs avec
beaucoup d'amendements déposés sur ce
taxi 140 ne modifie pas effectivement
les grands équilibres ni les principales
dispositions du texte
donc moi je me réjouis de l'adhésion du
sénat à ses orientations et d'autant
plus que je pense que la crise que nous
traversons confirme que les français
attendent qu'on améliore leur
déplacement du quotidien qu on les
simplifie et c'est bien l'objet de ce
texte
donc ça confirme l'importance et
l'urgence de ce texte pour vous une
bonne solution de flécher la tei cpe
vers les infrastructures de transport
c'est là est bien l'une des propositions
qui est fait par le rapporteur didier
mon délire alors je vous confirme que
cette année il ya bien 1,2 milliard de
thijs cpe qui est affecté au financement
des infrastructures donc à l' agence de
financement des infrastructures qui a
adopté son budget la semaine dernière un
budget qui va nous permettre de tenir
les engagements qui ont été pris par le
gouvernement
ce sont des projets qui sont très
attendues ces améliorations des
transports du quotidien c'est essentiel
c'est plus important que jamais donc
jouera sur le budget et bien été adoptée
de la fille pour 2019
alors quid de la vignette poids lourds
on sait qu'il ya eu des discussions à ce
sujet on sait que l'une des difficultés
c'est que l'on ne peut pas faire une
vignette poids lourd spécialement pour
les poids lourds venus de l'étranger
votre réflexion est encore en cours sur
ce sujet alors vous savez que on a
toujours indiqué que pour 2020 il
fallait réfléchir effectivement à une
nouvelle recette donc vous comprendrez
que c'est évidemment un sujet qui est
débattue dans le cas de grands débats
moi je vais pas présenté les conclusions
du grand débat j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire je pense que et quand je me déplace
dans les territoires à l'occasion du
grand débat ou à d'autres occasions je
vois des français qui en effet voit
passer beaucoup de poids lourds
étrangers qui font le plein en belgique
en luxembourg et puis ensuite en espagne
et qui utilisent nos infrastructures
sans participer au financement
donc je continue à penser que c'est une
bonne piste de travail pour conclure il
habite bande certains sénateurs jugent
que le texte n'est pas offre à ses
offensives sur la question de l'ubs et
risation des transports à je cite
certains sénateurs de gauche c'est une
véritable gangrène qui mine la cohésion
de notre pays il faut t'il mieux réguler
et bien cette numérisation des trans
alors c'est bien l'objet du texte à la
fois de se dire qu'on a beaucoup de
nouvelles solutions que les plateformes
numériques peuvent apporter beaucoup de
nouvelles solutions mais que bien
évidemment on doit s'assurer que ça se
fait pas au détriment des travailleurs
qui notamment donc fournissent les
services de ces plateformes avec
disposition dans le texte qui visait
justement à permettre la mise en place
de chartes dans ses plateformes
il ya eu un amendement de suppression
mais on aura l'occasion d'en rediscuter
je ne doute pas
en séance et moi je me réjouis par
avance de du débat qu'on va pouvoir
avoir sur ce texte à dire effectivement
merci beaucoup et isabelle bande d'avoir
répondu à mes questions alors qu'on va
avoir l'occasion de vous revoir au sénat
puisque effectivement l'examen du texte
commence dans quelques jours en séance
merci beaucoup et également et bien à
mes côtés il y à issy bien nicole
belloubet nicole belloubet la garde des
sceaux qui a été largement interrogé
lors de cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
bien sûr après et bien les événements
les agressions de condé sur sarthe
les surveillants demandent une
revalorisation sécuritaire indemnitaire
statutaire allez vous pouvoir répondre à
ses revendications
alors d'abord je voudrais dire que la
préoccupation de la sécurité dans les
établissements pénitentiaires est une
préoccupation très forte de ce
gouvernement
nous avons pris depuis l'année dernière
un nombre important de mesures
je le rappelais à madame la sénatrice
goulet qui m'a interrogé sur ce sujet
nous avons pris des mesures en matière
de traitement des détenus qui sont
radicalisées des mesures en matière de
sécurité des établissements
pénitentiaires et des mesures également
en faveur de la sécurité des personnels
nouvelle mesure a pour l'instant pour
autant manifestement ces événements
montrent qu'il y à une défaillance soit
dans nos réglementations soient dans la
mise en oeuvre général de ces
réglementations comme vous le savez j'ai
demandé à l'inspection générale de la
justice de se rendre dans
l'établissement pour mesurer la manière
dont les choses s'étaient déroulées
parce qu'en effet c'est paradoxal qu'une
telle situation se soit déroulé à
condé-sur-sarthe celles établies salma
aussi ses séries n'était pas en
surpopulation car voilà exactement c'est
un aux deux établissements les plus
sécuritaires et nous n'avons pas de
surpopulation donc ce n'est pas
seulement une question moyens donc nous
devons voir ce qui s'est passé et en
tirer les règles générales lors de
l'examen du projet de loi justice le
rapporteur françois noël buffet avait
proposé de renforcer les fouille des
visiteurs dans les prisons à l'époque où
vous y étiez opposé
alors quelle raison est ce que vous avez
changé d'avis quand vous n'en voyez ce
qui s'est passé là s'ils voulaient
d'abord dans la loi de réforme de la
justice
nous avons modifié un article sur les
fouilles des détenus qui correspondait
également à une demande forte des
syndicats des personnels pénitentiaires
et nous a semblé que c'était de bon sens
donc nous avons modifié cela pour
permettre tout en restant conforme à la
réglementation européenne et nationale
nous avons accru ses possibilités de
fouilles sur la fouille des visiteurs
si je n'avais pas accédé à cette demande
c'est parce qu'il me semblait que il
n'était pas interdit par notre propre
réglementation de procéder à de telles
foules donc il faut vérifier cela et il
faut mesurer la pratique également fait
référence ya peut-être à ce sujet que
l'on voit que absolument c'était un
couteau a porté les coups
une visiteuse ce sera les conclusions du
rapport d'inspection que j'ai demandé
toute dernière question à ce que vous
jugez qu'aujourd'hui nos prisons sont
aptes à incarcérer des revenants des
terroristes revenus d'irak ou de syrie
en voyant tout ce débat sur la
radicalisation et piaget difficulté est
bien mais juguler cela dans une eau mais
il n'y a pas de doute là dessus
nous sommes parfaitement en mesure de
pouvoir accueillir dans nos
établissements pénitentiaires des
personnes dont la dangerosité est avérée
quelle qu'en soit la raison mais y
compris des personnes qui sont soit des
détenus terroristes soient des personnes
radicaliser nous sommes parfaitement en
capacité de les prendre en charge
nous en avons déjà accueilli soit des
personnes qui sont radicalisés en france
et qui sont restés ici soit des
personnes qui sont parties en syrie ou
ailleurs et qui sont revenus en france
il y en a déjà quelques-uns dans nos
établissements pénitentiaires donc
évidemment nous les accueillons ce qui
ne veut pas dire si c'est la question
sous jacente que la france a changé de
position je le redis ici nous
n'accueillons pas de nouvelles personnes
revenues des terrains de combat bien
merci beaucoup une telle dérive et
d'avoir répondu à mes questions
merci beaucoup au tas mais on va revenir
pendant vingt minutes encore sur cette
séance de questions d'actualité au
gouvernement et pour ce faire chaque
oeil sur le plateau emmanuel capus
bonjour bonjour alors vous êtes sénateur
du maine et loire membre du groupe
indépendant république et territoires et
on l'a vu cette séance de questions
d'actualité
elle a été marquée par la thématique des
droits des femmes à la veille de la
journée internationale du droit des
femmes vous êtes notamment
vice-président de la délégation
sénatoriale aux entreprises on l'a
entendu il ya des indicateurs qui ont
été créés dans les entreprises est-ce
que ça suffit pour finalement renforcer
l'égalité femmes hommes
alors je suis vice-président de la
délégation d'entreprises je suis aussi
avocat dans la vie et ma vraie qualité
principale c'est droit du travail
justement je pense qu'il y a
effectivement beaucoup de mesures ont
déjà été prises il ya eu les accords
d'entreprise sur l'égalité hommes femmes
qui ont été prises par le passé
aujourd'hui on a un index supplémentaire
qui est pris il ya un principe général
du droit qui est très général et qui
parle de l'égalité de traitement
mais de façon générale or seulement
entre les hommes et les femmes et ça
s'applique évidemment aussi hot entre
les hommes et les femmes à part
du moment où c'est à travail égal
salaire égal donc les outils juridiques
je pense qu'ils existent déjà
je pense que ce qu'il faut changer ils
sont donc ce qu'il faut changer c'est la
mentalité l'index va permettre
effectivement de savoir pour certaines
femmes si elles sont seulement dans les
grandes dames
alors oui dans les grands groupes mais
après c'est pour ça que je pense que les
choses changeront quand on changera les
mentalités ça c'est pour l'égalité
salariale qui est extrêmement importante
puisqu'on c'est qu'effectivement on a
d'abord les femmes sont majoritaires à
travailler en france aux 52 % des
travailleurs sont des femmes et elles
sont payées 9% de moins que les hommes
en général
moi je pense qu'effectivement il faut
continuer à changer les mentalités pour
que notamment dans les petites
entreprises
on considère totalement anormal qu'une
femme soit moins payés qu'à nommer ya
pas que ça parce que l'égalité hommes
femmes ça ne passe pas que par l'égalité
salariale
ça passe également énormément par les
promotions sociales la ministre l'a dit
d'ailleurs c'était bien les promotions
sociales et promotion de carrière de
carrière les évolutions de carrière et
puis l'émotion en politique aussi la
femme engagée à l'or a beaucoup de
postes de pouvoir
les femmes je pense que c'est en train
de changer ça prend du temps nous dans
notre groupe effectivement on n'a pas
beaucoup de femmes on se faisait la
réflexion en séance on aimerait en avoir
plus
le mode des modes de scrutins font qu'
on va avoir beaucoup plus de femmes
puisque dans tous les scrutins de liste
maintenant il ya la parité donc petit à
petit les choses vont se faire
moi je viens d'un milieu où il ya eu je
travaille quasiment qu'avec des femmes
puisque je suis dans le monde de la
justice
chez ça c'est fait depuis longtemps et
naturellement dans le montage il ya
beaucoup de femmes donc seul ce n'est
pas une cause désespérée
les femmes ont toute leur place elles
prennent de plus en plus de place et je
veux dire et dans le monde politique je
pense qu'elles vont le prendre et je
voulais terminer par le fait qu' il faut
et aussi dans le monde salarial qu'on
aide énormément les femmes à gérer les
absences pour pour les de la natalité
pour les congés maternité parce que
souvent à la carrière souvent c'est
aussi encore maintenant et c'est
dramatique
un handicap dans la promotion de
carrière et ça c'est totalement anormal
alors justement sur ce sujet il ya une
question séance et c
mu 1 la ministre de la santé qui a
répondu sur le cas particulier de la
hausse des féminicides en france on les
écoute concrètes ont déjà été prises
j'en citerai quelques unes et vous le
savez les moyens financiers sont
conséquents puisque 3 530 millions
d'euros ont été inscrits au plf 2010 9
donc c'est un budget important je crois
le plus important jamais dédiée à cette
cause de l'égalité entre les femmes et
des hommes mais vous m'interrogez sur
les violences faites aux femmes sur les
féminicides nous sommes engagés très
rapidement sur la création de centres de
prise en charge du psycho traumatismes
notamment dédié aux femmes victimes de
violences sexuelles est victime de
violence tout court de leur conjoint
nous avons fait un appel à projet n'a
pas la candidature l'année dernière ces
dix centres ont été créés labellisés
nous sommes le premier pays au monde à
organiser des réseaux de prise en charge
des victimes de psycho traumatisme
emmanuelle capiez on né le 7 mars et a
déjà eu trente femmes qui sont mortes
sous leurs sous les coups de leur
compagnon ou ex-compagnon depuis le
début de l'année en france
c'est une situation inacceptable cette
situation inacceptable et ce d'autant
plus que effectivement dans la question
nous a dit qu'il n'avait pas plus de
réponse pénale
ces faits d'homicides de féminicide donc
c'est inacceptable j'espère que là après
que le gouvernement a pris en compte ces
augmentations et le les centres de prise
en charge des victimes
sa part est un outil extrêmement utile
et intéressant pour essayer de sortir
les femmes qui sont menacés de ce
contexte familial la réponse de jugement
ceux ci on en a vendu la dernière
victime elle avait 2
des signaux d'alerté avait prévenu la
police et pourtant rien n'a été fait moi
je pense de façon plus globale que le
budget de la justice doit être un budget
c'est ce que je défends la commission
des finances qui doit être sanctuarisé
même augmenté parce que c'est ça le vrai
pouvoir régalien d'état et c'est là
dessus qu'on doit mettre le paquet merci
emmanuel capus sur un tout autre sujet
on va rejoindre ta mme tran huy qui est
avec le ministre de l'agriculture didier
guillaume oui elle avait dû vie mais on
va commencer par une question sur la
place des femmes dans l'agriculture on
sait que la place est parfois compliqué
qu est ce que vous avez fait pour les
femmes dans l'agriculture au niveau de
l'exécutif ces dernières années à la
veille du 8 mars du vide il ya beaucoup
de beaucoup d'efforts ont été faits au
niveau des femmes en général mais dans
l'agriculture également dans la mesure
où il ya beaucoup de femmes
agricultrices chef d'exploitation
donc nous avons mis en place des droits
nouveaux notamment pour les congés de
maternité notamment pour le remplacement
il est indispensable qu'une femme
agricultrice du brain ses congés de
maternité qu'elle puisse être remplacée
pour son travail et nous avançons
beaucoup avec marlène schiappa dont
l'enfant une visite sur des
exploitations tenue exclusivement par
des femmes parce qu'elles sont
nombreuses et motivez votre bilan sinon
du salon de l'agriculture alors que le
monde agricole fait bien depuis
plusieurs années face à la ghriba chine
sur la question des pesticides les
fermes usines le bien-être animal
il ya bien des sujets sur lesquels le
monde agricole doit se défendre
aujourd'hui oui le bilan du champ de la
culture et un bilan très positif ça a
été un salon totalement tourné vers les
françaises et les français nous avons
montré ce qui t'est d'agriculture
françaises une cure d'excellence une
alimentation sur scène et durable et le
visage qui a montré d'agriculture
françaises qui ont montré toutes les
filières a été formidable en effet la
culture est en train de muter la culture
se transforme la culture va vers
l'agroécologie cette transition est
indispensable et c'est comme cela que
les françaises et des français je crois
non perçues c'était un très bon salon
salon très positif vous mettez l'accent
sur l'agroécologie d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui lors du déplacement des
manuels macro à gréoux-les-bains sur le
thème de l'environnement il ya eu
énormément de questions qui ont concerné
l'agriculture sur le loup le bio la loi
foncière
vous ne regrettez pas de ne pas y être
allé pour pouvoir répondre à ce type de
questions ah non mais d'abord chez le
président de la république qui répond
c'est pas les mini géants voit quand
tout cas l'environnement
je fais tour de rôle oui l'agriculture
est très présente l'agriculture et la
ruralité sont les fondements même de
notre société
fair nation faire france sait tenir
compte de cette ruralité et de cette
agriculture et donc les questions
aujourd'hui posée au président la
république sur le bio sur la transition
écologique sur le prédateur sont des
questions qui traversent toute
l'agriculture et j'ai j'ai entendu ce
qu'a répondu le président de la
république évidemment je suis totalement
dans cette dans cette ligne là c'est par
la transition agro écologique que nous y
arriverons
c'est par une nouvelle façon
d'appréhender la culture et en même
temps c'est en soutenant les
agriculteurs en soutenant les éleveurs
de nos montées sèches comme dans les
alpes-de-haute-provence face aux
prédateurs face aux loups y d'hélium
pour conclure eh bien ce sont
l'agriculture a bien sûr été marquée
comme chaque année par l'avis du
président de la république emmanuel
macron sa visite s'est bien passé ça a
été plutôt à une promenade de santé
alors qu'on pouvait attendre les gilet
jaune
il ya sur les réseaux sociaux des
accusations à l'égard de la république
en marche qu'ils jugent quelques la
république en mars a mobilisé 200
militants pour soutenir le président de
la république qu'est ce que vous leur
répondez et déjà su les cas je vais pas
aux réseaux sociaux parce que y'a
tellement d'absurdité sur les réseaux
sociaux trudeau il n'y a pas que des
absurdités mais comment faire mettre des
militants enfin c'est là s'était ouvert
au public et beaucoup de monde
il a eu des discussions avec avec tous
les gens qui étaient là qu'est ce que ça
veut dire se rendaient dans une société
complotistes on est dans une société
comme on dit en patois drômois de fake
news
je crois qu'il faut reprendre la réalité
ce qui a peut-être ennui est certain
c'est que le président de la république
a répondu aux questions que se posait le
monde agricole les agriculteurs c'est
qu'il a fait un discours de plus d'une
heure qui était très apprécié par tous
les syndicats agricoles qu'il a pris la
mesure de ce kit est l'agriculture
française la souveraineté alimentaire de
ce que devait être l'agriculture dans
l'europe et je pense que c'est pour ça
que là la visite s'est bien passée
c'était pas uniquement une promenade de
santé parce que quand on a dans plus de
14 heures
c'est une voix un vrai exercice un vrai
marathon de santé marathon de santé
merci beaucoup d'idées guillaume d'avoir
répondu à la question
merci tam et autres thèmes abordés lors
de cette séance de questions d'actualité
au gouvernement la politique
industrielle de la france et c'est agnès
pannier relâché secrétaire d'état à
l'économie qui a répondu sur cette
question on les écoute depuis 20 ans
l'emploi industriel a diminué de 1
million un million et depuis deux ans il
progresse et pourquoi parce que nous
avons mis en place une politique
industrielle ambitieuse
premièrement une politique a dû une
politique industrielle qui permet le
développement de l'activité économique
en rendant la plateforme françaises plus
compétitives
c'est ça qui explique que toyota
investit 300 millions d'euros en france
daimler 500 millions d'euros en france
et que nous sommes désormais la première
destination des investissements directs
à l'étranger pour l'industrie manal
capus on entend que la ministre la
france crée des emplois industriels
et pourtant on entend parler de ford
d'ascq ovale
il ya une question aussi sur un groupe
allemand dans le domaine sucrier qui
fermait comme ça de manière unilatérale
est ce qu'il ya une politique
industrielle volontariste du
gouvernement
moi je pense que sur cette question là
je ne crois pas qu'on puisse dire que ce
gouvernement est pas sensible à la
politique industrielle et à l'industrie
dont moi je serai attendant j'aurais
tendance à penser que la réponse de
l'espagne est assez forte et moi me
satisfait pour que moi en train de ces
grands groupes étrangers de fermer comme
ford par exemple il ya deux choses en
fait il ya le verre à moitié plein et le
moins le verre à moitié vide
agnès pannier c'est son rôle l axe sur
le verre à moitié plein elle explique ce
qui va bien et c'est quand même une ex
décisif à une assez bonne le fait qu'on
ait plus d'emplois dans l'industrie
depuis deux ans donc ça je ne faut pas
faire de politique politicienne faut
s'en féliciter
en revanche évidemment ça n'écarte pas
le fait qu'il ya des déceptions et des
échecs
jérôme bignon a rappelé celui de soudou
coeur qui veut fermer trois sites en
france dans l'industrie sucrière et
betteravière ça c'est pas acceptable
le rôle de l'état à ce niveau là et ça a
été très clairement dit par didier
guillaume c'est de faire pression sur le
groupe qui plus est un groupe allemand
pour que ça ne ferme pas ou qu'on trouve
solution européenne sur la filière
sucrière et puis il ya la question
blanquefort une forme on à l usine ford
qui ferme maintenant le rôle de l'état
faut pas se mentir il ya des solutions
qui sont proposées par madame marie ben
ma collègue socialiste qui dit il
faudrait qu'une prise de participation
temporaire de l'état ça ne marche pas on
laissé par le passé c'est absolument pas
le rôle de l'état de racheter une usine
qui est inquiétant fakih qui ferment
moyens face et ses chronos américain
elle propose effectivement
éventuellement de s'appuyer davantage
sur les régions je suis suis tout à fait
favorable
elle propose de créer des grandes
coopératives européennes de type airbus
j'y suis tout à fait favorable ce qu'il
faut de façon plus globale c'est
effectivement avoir une politique
industrielle forte et avoir une
politique de compétitivité des
entreprises qui soit forte
ça veut dire un coût du travail moins
élevé ça veut dire une fiscalité des
entreprises moins élevé pour que les
entreprises n'est pas un intérêt se
délocaliser alors pour le coût du
travail moins élevés ces entreprises
elles ont touché des aides quand elles
ferment comme ça des sites industriels
faut qu'elle ait remboursé z
je serai pas te ce serait pas totalement
illogique effectivement si elles ont
touché des années qu'elle parte il
serait normal qu'elle remboursera danois
et concrètement comment on fait pour
encourager encore davantage la création
on a entendu un nombre d'emplois non
pourvus dans l'industrie faut travailler
sur quoi sur la formation et sur
l'apprentissage un gros travail sur la
formation il ya énormément moi dans ma
région
on a énormément où on a un taux de
chômage assez faibles plus faible que la
moyenne nationale
on a énormément d'emplois que l'on ne
réussit pas à pourvoir
donc il faut travailler sur la formation
vont travailler sur l'accès à des
emplois dans l'industrie faut travailler
faire la mobilité aussi parce qu'il ya
des endroits en france où il ya des gens
qui n'ont pas de travail et d'autres où
on cherche des travailleurs il faut
travailler sur sur la sur la
compétitivité des entreprises
autre sujet un peu lié tout de même
l'europe ça y est la campagne des
élections européennes est lancé
les républicains ont publié leurs listes
hier en marche on a vu emmanuel macron
il a écrit une lettre aux européens pour
une renaissance de l'europe vous êtes
délégué national d'agir vous soutenez la
république en marche sur les élections
européennes
même nous on a pris une position qui est
très clair hier agir soutiendra une
liste de rassemblement avec en marche
avec les radicaux avec tout ce qu'ils
veulent avec les amis d'alain juppé et
de jean pierre raffarin
tous ceux qui veulent effectivement
faire progresser l'europe suivre le
programme le projet qui a été envoyé à
tous les citoyens européens par emmanuel
macron lundi plus de liberté plus de
progrès plus de construction collective
de l'europe oui effectivement agir après
position très claire et moi je
soutiendrai la liste de rappel la
république en marche
je vous remercie emmanuel capus d'avoir
été mon invité pour revenir sur cette
triche séance de questions d'actualité
au gouvernement et on retourne voir
thème traduit en salle des conférences
du sénat puisque tam vous êtes avec jean
françois longeot sénateur union
centriste du doubs et oui et avec jean
françois longeot nous allons parler
ensemble delà du projet de loi
l'homme qui va arriver d'ici quelques
jours au sénat outre le problème du
financement vous jugez vous que ce
projet de loi ne vient pas suffisamment
répondre aux problèmes de la ruralité
pourquoi oui effectivement c'est vrai
que nous en sommes aperçus ce projet de
loi correspond à une réalité sur le
domaine urbain mais sur la ruralité il
manque beaucoup de choses et
effectivement c'est pour ça que moi j'ai
proposé je vais déposer un amendement
notamment en matière de transports parce
que c'est vrai que nous avons pas dans
les secteurs ruraux tous les équipements
transport que ce soit le tram le métro
est haute et donc pour les personnels
qui veulent aller travailler et qui
habitent dans des petites villes et qui
veulent travailler dans des endroits un
peu éloigné a je crois que il est
important que nous puissions apporter
notre contribution et que cette loi
permette effectivement par exemple
d'utiliser le mode de transport scolaire
pour effectivement les salariés pour que
chacune et chacun puisse se déplacer
correctement et se rendre au travail ce
qui est ce que c'est paradoxal que ce
projet de loi ne soit pas suffisamment
présents sur ce thème là alors même que
ce sont les thèmes qui est soit à
l'origine du mouvement de gilet jaune
sept problèmes d de désenclavement qu'il
faut y c'est assez paradoxal mais c'est
vrai que c'est ça peut paraître dès fois
compliqué hein effectivement de modifier
les modes de transport dans le monde
rural parce qu'aujourd'hui endroit là
par la voiture
1 vous n'avez pas d'autres modes de
transport il ya beaucoup de volets sur
le vélo sur choses comme ça dans cette
loi mais nous c'est pas c'est pas un
outil facile à utiliser pour se rendre
au travail ou d'ailleurs pour avoir
diverses activités que ce soit des
activités associatives ou supporter et
donc il est important que nous puissions
faire des propositions et nous puissions
effectivement faire entendre non pas
d'une façon
efforts plus haute mais de faire
entendre la voix du secteur rural bien
merci beaucoup jean françois longeot
d'avoir remercier à mes questions verse
alors que ce projet de loi nome va être
examiné dans quelques jours au sénat
merci mot quota mais avant ce qui t'est
un dernier détour par l'hémicycle pour
retrouver alexandre pousse à alexandre
il y a actuellement une proposition de
loi des propositions de loi communiste
et une notamment sur l'interdiction des
lanceurs de balles de défense les ailes
bd et où germé sur cette question des
ailes bd il va y avoir un affrontement
politique entre d'un côté la gauche du
sénat qui est pour l'interdiction de ces
lanceurs de balles de défense et de
l'autre côté la majorité sénatoriale qui
estime que cette interdiction
fragiliserait l'action des forces de
l'ordre face aux manifestants violents
alors concrètement ce texte des
sénateurs communistes demandent
l'interdiction immédiate de l' usage de
ses armes non létales par les forces de
l'ordre
les sénateurs communistes demandent
aussi plus de transparence il souhaite
qu à chaque lendemain de manifestations
les chiffres sur l' usage de ces armes
par les policiers soient rendus publics
alors la commission des lois du sénat a
rejeté cette proposition d'interdiction
la majorité du sénat est contre car elle
estime que ces lbd permettent une
réponse graduée des forces de l'ordre à
ces manifestants violents et donc peu
probable que clb dès ce soir soit
interdite par les sénateurs merci
beaucoup alexandre poussard et c'est
déjà la fin de cette édition merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi à 18h30 vous
retrouvez l'émission on va plus loin
excellente suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]